a waste of time
that's not great
um I just had a question about the
level generator
yep
um basically just trying to extend it so
that we can spawn like like just random
decorational elements uh on the tiles
like Tim's anti-tank traps and stuff
like that no yep
uh where in the code should that go in
order for it to like work properly
because I'm seeing a few places and I'm
like
I don't know where this goes well it's a
little bit
tough because you wanted to possess and
so
but do you want to despawn for each
chunk
uh
well yeah like that's not that easy to
do because obviously like the level
Spawner in the handles tiles
um and it does so by reusing
uh you know existing kind of entities it
doesn't instantiate and Destroy and
whatever so slapping this in
um
like you'd basically have to it's I
guess I would do it in and it depends
like I guess you would want to generate
these positions based on a certain noise
value
um
and I don't know like I mean set tile
like if you look at the set tile
function inside the level generator
like set sorry set chunk yeah
so that gets called every time you go to
a different chunk boundary
and it's responsible for basically
resetting that entire three by three
chunk system to something else and you
can see there's a branch that
not that checks to see if it's not null
and that's the cached version and then
the one below it is the I'm creating
this chunk for the first time version
obviously based on existing noise data
but the point is you could put it like
somewhere I guess in one of those
but like again like that's this I don't
think that's going to be trivial
because you wanted to persist so you
need to generate it I mean I could
probably put it in
uh I mean honestly like if if it doesn't
persist I don't think it's
strictly the worst thing because I'm
gonna be an indifferent right yeah
like I'm fine with it not like
persisting per se yeah well then all you
have to really do is you see where it
like for example there's
um
well yeah like what the place at the
very end of the function there's Place
General tent
um so that's where it does the placing
uh because it's not going to be in the
first few chunks that are generated so
you can basically do it like
um after that
you could have like uh
you know somewhere in there it can
decide to place
um
and you but the thing is you need to to
check the uh location of it
like I said to check the like where you
can place it
um you need to use
I think
yeah get tile but
I'm trying to figure out the actual
coordinate of it
uh well CX is the parameter that's
passed in CX that's basically the chunk
index as far as world space goes so in
other words it goes negative and stuff
so you could probably just multiply that
by like 16.
so I'll just like let me share my screen
and I'll just roughly show you what I'm
thinking but try try something like this
like
um
like it's probably like CX
times the chunk
I don't know if this will exactly work
but chunk size and then plus basically
uh so that can be like your Min Bound
for randomness
um and then Max would be
uh
you know Min Plus
um the chunk of the tile width basically
uh and the tile width is in tiles no
wait that's that's the width of each
tile and we have the chunk size is 16 so
basically you know plus 16 tiles
um and that would be why is that bad
on the real studio is just as tight as I
am
um yeah that's fine so you could do
something like that you could generate
between those two positions and then
that would be maybe your X and then the
Z would be tile height instead of width
yeah but somewhat somewhere if you
generate a random number between these
two
then I think that should be an
appropriate spot and then you can pass
that into get tile to figure out what
tile is underneath that
yeah
um
um so like
I don't know
anyway you get the point I think
hopefully
and be like
Min plus Vector three
uh sorry Hazel random
fact three
times
Max minus min
or whatever
yeah
and then you pass that in here
okay
cool
um that should work I know it's not
working
oh I don't know I flipped it I flipped
it now should work yeah it does work
it's just Visual Studio having a problem
I'll pass that card for you
yeah
um and obviously I can you know because
if I can just generate that pulse
randomly X number of times
um to get you know a certain number of
objects in a chunk
yes yeah well yeah
but of course it's random and it's not
going to be guaranteed distance away
from things and like I mean between you
and me like the get tile function like I
still I'm not 100 convinced that it's
right it seems to be though because I
had I had to highlight the tile that was
under the player and it was like it
wasn't like 100 accurate but what it was
like
within like a few centimeters or
whatever so
it seems to work and the idea is I think
because you guys
like because the origin of the hexagon
is like up here at the top
it should that y value should in fact be
you know the height it's just that
obviously you'll have to um make sure if
the sandbags I don't know where their
origin is
but but
it's weird because like again what I do
is I literally when I spawn enemies I
take this like I take the tiles Y and
then I add you know a meter or two to it
to get the enemy up here and yet
sometimes they still fall through the
world so I'm not 100 sure if that's
because this is wrong and it's spawning
in here and it going down or whatever or
if um maybe they're just like you know
laterally off and they're spawning in a
place that has the the trunk hasn't
generated yet I don't know there's
there's lots of problems and I'd like to
rewrite this whole game to be completely
honest
but yeah but how are we in terms of so I
think there's some kind of main menu is
there
it's working just fine
um
like you can play through it
um if you
if you get shot enough to wear your um
off your level goes to zero you lose the
cup and you have to go back and pick up
another one
um yep if you deliver the coffee
currently it just Fades to Black and
then goes to the main menu we kind of
we're talking about okay well we should
probably have maybe a one or two voice
lines there like the general basically
saying like would work or whatever
to make it slightly more interesting
yeah
but I don't know if we necessarily had
time for that maybe we could add that
like afterwards that's just a little
detail yeah
um so basically as far as I see in my
plan like is the tutorial right that
hasn't been done
well both audio and tutorial
there's basically four hours left so
that's a long time like I should be able
to assuming audio actually works like
engine side and there's no I don't run
into major issues like it should be easy
to get both of those done any physics
any system has been touched yeah has
been riddled with problems renderer
physics Warrior has had a big render
hasn't really had any problems
render like building acid packs has
crashed multiple times because of
renderer
that hasn't happened are you sure it's
an actual crash not just an asset
uh yeah it's a crash because it crashes
on like one of the right descriptor sets
how is that possible I've been building
asset packs this whole jam and I haven't
had a single crash not only that uh I've
also gotten several uh device lost
arrows while building the assets yeah
that's that's that's okay it's just the
asset pack the reason that happens is
because there's like a
it's the Q it's the it's the queue
submission I think well at least that's
what it is for me they just assessed
though but I don't understand because I
I swear like I have not had a single
crash when building asset packs
and I've been building obviously I built
them a lot because I was fixing the
runtime
so it's very bizarre but I'll be doing
the build anyway so that's lucky
yeah
and I have gotten some device lost
errors
yeah the audio Yeah
well I'm that's why I'm saying that like
assuming that goes well I should have
enough time
but if it doesn't then yeah
but what are you gonna start with
yeah uh what am I going to start with
the tutorial because that's more
important than the Audio I think
well what do you mean how's someone
going to play the game if they'd spawned
in and they have no idea what to do
we didn't we shouldn't you guys
shouldn't have made this main menu like
this is exactly what happened with
Forest like the main you don't need a
main menu you basically just spawn in
and you start the game and that's it
like why why have a main menu that
explains everything
especially if there's going to be a
tutorial
because at the end of the game they can
find out but the thing is this is at the
end of the day it's a game jam and I
think that like
you need to have a way like someone it's
it's you're essentially making a
prototype of a game and so if you die if
you jump in like I think people can
forgive like oh yeah they haven't
managed to do audio but again it's not
like I'm gonna have time for no audio
like it takes two seconds to slap in a
sound effect and you're allowed to fix
bugs post launch so as long as I make
the sound effect it doesn't even matter
if it works or not like I can still I
can just fix the audio engine during
like the rest of today because it's 7am
but the uh if there's no tutorial
content then obviously like it's like
you jump in player doesn't know what to
do they're like whatever the next game
but I don't think they'll be like oh
this game has no audio yeah let me just
move on
like it's a I think that's it's really
important to have like an experience
like when you jump in it guides you
through like this is what you have to do
because people aren't going to have the
patience to play to play games you know
and to actually be like all right let me
go back to the main menu read the
controls again how do I get back I have
to restart the whole game like oh
where's the text that file that explains
like where's the where's the game
submission page that explains what the
controls are like nah you gotta have
everything in the game
anyway
um
but that being said again there should
be enough time I think what I want to do
is I'm going to literally grab the
ambience from dichotomy
uh because we have ambience in dichotomy
and I'm just going to Chuck that in and
that'll be my test for saying
if it works or not
foreign
all right Peter um so I guess I'll just
go and start doing all of this
yep I'll just get like the decorations
certainly working well obviously working
and then I'll
uh push that and just
Focus mail on bug fixing and play
testing some more
yep yeah sounds good
cool all right see ya
okay
um
I might just
[Music]
gotta put some headphones on
all right
um so
let's take a look at
peaky
this microphone oh and now it's like
really quiet
until this is like last level of gain
here is so precise it sucks
all right anyway yeah like look I'm
peeking now
but then if I make it this much quieter
it's now like it's like not
the heck man all right whatever yeah
this kind of sucks
um
actually use a different mic
I don't know
we'll see all right so yeah this sucks
I don't like this distorted this whole
Jam
that's so strange that like no well
that's fine I think
this should be okay hopefully ugh anyway
no time for that um
uh if we look at dichotomy
um
dichotomy as um audio I believe
so we can steal uh it's called this city
Ambience thing which isn't even mine
it's like some royalty free Ambience or
whatever I don't even know where it's
from to be honest I'm gonna pretend to
not know uh let's make a folder called
audio
Source paste it in here all right so if
we go into oh I should probably yeah
let's build the scripts and stuff
did Peter add any new files uh maybe he
did I don't know
should probably uh regenerate the
project
do this
build this and I guess it did
um
I don't know if this is gonna work
okay good oh there's a compass that's
cool
Why is the
oh no
okay if the control is connected it
sometimes glitches out that's right
there
all right
is it not F to pick out odds a now
why'd you guys change it from F to E
Tim
[Music]
right
I mean F's used a lot though
[Music]
maybe should be both like like a kid
right f is f used for anything I can't
make it both the easier it is the better
um all right so the enemies spawn
I guess I'll try and deliver the coffee
Yep they're over there
oh are they oh cool there's a texture
for them oh they look sick I like the
enemies Tim
yeah they look nice
they look funny though
all right well I'm ignoring these
weirdos
my man they're shooting me pretty well
though
there needs to be like I don't think
there's unless Peter's added it I don't
think there's the concept of accuracy at
all
for shooting and there really needs to
be because otherwise they just Ray cast
you directly wait where's the general
aren't my gun's out of ammo and there's
no melee or jumping on enemies oh
there's a general
can I give him a coffee
no I guess
let me ask Peter quickly
[Music]
all right so now let's uh Pop the Music
on pause for the actual stream
um and let's see
uh
let's I should have whatever
um let's see if we can get
audio working in the engine so
basically we have to make a sound config
I'll call this
ambience
we'll pick our uh thing
okay that's playing
right
yes that's definitely playing it's
actually this is probably the worst
effect but whatever because it's so hard
to hear
um like it's quiet it's ambience
um we can sure we'll send it a bit to
the Reverb make it a bit smoother
turn it up you guys should be able to
hear that
it's probably loud
how do people do live streams like am I
just a bad streamer like how do people
do
because the worst thing about this is
it's like impossible for me to hear what
the stream hears I would like to hear
what the stream is
like that would kind of be ideal to be
honest I don't see why I would want to
hear anything else like and I know I can
monitor the inputs but is I don't know
if that's
like post pre or post fader like inside
the audio mixer and Hazel like and so on
it's weird
anyway whatever I'm not going to tell
this out now but like how do people
stream like surely they have that there
because I guess if I was trying to
stream I'd want to hear that the audio
like why would I want to hear audio that
isn't what the stream is
so I guess that way I would just want to
hear the stream out and put audio
because I like because with my audio
interface I'm just mixing a little bit
of my mic into my ears so that I can
actually hear myself
because otherwise because I'm wearing
headphones
um
uh and it's kind of nice like having the
the mix
for the audio
um but whatever all right so we have the
sound config so basically we have to
open up the audio events editor
make like
um
show an event called Ambience add an
action
we'll make a play action for it um the
asset is going to be the sound config
and I think
that's kind of all we have to do right
if we save that
I don't think we have to save it but um
or maybe we do a move to save the
project I don't remember how it works
but if I now just go to like I don't
know the camera or the player now let's
go to the camera We'll add the ambience
or even level generator can
have Ambience because that's like the
level so if I well first of all know the
camera
the camera has to have an audio listener
so I'm gonna add an audio listener
um
uh because we probably don't have it
anywhere else
foreign
and
then we will add
to the level generator let's add
um audio
and then start event and this is like
you have to type it in manually which is
a bit lame but Ambience and then I can
do play on awake oh and then in the
sound config we can make sure this is
looping
and that I think is it
like if I just hit play
I hear the audio which is fantastic so
yeah the audio the audio Works Tim
build sound bank now actually that's not
the full story because let's um
we'll also build a Shader pack let's
actually test it out in the run time now
because that's important so if I build
the asset pack which Peter says crashes
see it asserts and but the asserters are
harmless like threading error in Vulcan
which again it shouldn't happen but you
know it's fine and here's another one
and it's only breaking because I've got
a break point on it
and that's it so I don't have any issues
building at all
but good to know that there are problems
um
more more to fix post launch okay so
that's all built now so if I run the
runtime hopefully
this works
yeah it works
I can hear you guys can hear that
Ambience right
I mean it's City ambience
but I guess if I mix I kind of like it
though and it's easy I guess if I mix
that maybe with some like
you know
like gunfire
um
there's freesound.org is that a real
thing like is that good
I'm gonna probably make some of my own
effects but I just feel like
you can't fire or whatever I just feel
like um
War
noises
I'm gonna make this quiet
that's like perfect
oh yeah I like that
thank you
scrapping fabric
oh that's kind of cool
it's slowed down that's why it's like
it's pitched down as well
well that sounds great
um I guess I'll just download this
steals these I need to log in
do I have an account I feel like it's
been decades
well the channel is taken
so that there's a high probability that
I'm the one who took it
ah I just logged in I just guessed the
password and the username all right
that's nice
so what was the license just attribution
all right that works
um
okay so let's go into here
audio Source that's pasting in
all right Tim to make you happy I have
Ambience and gunfire already in
that took two seconds luckily
so
that's audio
so we make that looping we'll see about
the the multiplier I'll add some Reverb
I always add some Reverb uh yeah and I
think all we can do is we can go to the
audio event and add another action so
basically plays both of those sounds
um and that should be it
yeah I can hear that
that sounds pretty dope
well the gunfire I only really heard it
at the beginning
but I guess it does kind of taper off a
bit
I think if we look at the waveform
no but take tape is off like you know 45
seconds in whatever
um let's keep it
all right so that's done so we have
basically our Ambient sound design
um
what's next uh
yeah footstep sounds okay anyway I just
said I wouldn't do audio though I just
wanted to make sure that I wouldn't go
to do audio and then turns out audio
doesn't work um so audio works so that's
great
um let's save this uh I'll even add it
like for Peter and Co
um
the sound Bank
shouldn't be there
in fact let me be good and quickly edit
the git ignore
I am pretty glad I slept to be honest I
feel pretty good
I feel almost like a normal
day slash night um all right so files
uh
asset pack
um
monster Hazel
and HSB
okay uh
so what this means now is that we can
return
to doing
basically the tutorial situation which
also involves uh adding the ability to
like do screen space kind of text into
Hazel
um so at the moment we can't really do
text
um
and to do that like I said we can do
text but it has to be World space and I
want to just be able to do it in screen
space
um and I think that should be fairly
easy
I just want to look at because obviously
like we we do actually do that in the
run time like I said of course the
render is capable of that and stuff but
like you know when I hit Ctrl F3 in the
runtime you can see that we get all of
this text that actually uses the same
renderer that obviously the game does in
terms of how it renders texts and 2D
graphics and so we have all this kind of
stuff you know that um obviously is
running a screen space so I my plan is
just to kind of look up how I did that
because there's on render 2D and then
that sets the time so let me see what it
does so there's a render a 2d proj so it
uses a projection Matrix
uh that I'm guessing is just like set
based on bounds or something like what
does this get set up and I hate I really
should just restart Visual Studio
because everything's an error apparently
let me just quickly do that
I hate how Visual Studio eventually just
descends into
errors
hopefully that actually fixes it all
right
so
um
yeah so how does that work
where does this get set up
here it is so just it's just an auto
projection to the pixel width and height
okay
that's fine
although is that fine it means we have
to get the viewport we have to subtract
from the viewport
I guess that's okay though because then
everything everything is based on pixels
usually that's how you do
like 2D rendering on a screen like this
and then you have
because then you can actually be precise
with your
so yeah let me know
is it back
yeah up again okay good thanks guys
all right um
I was saying um yeah so this is kind of
yeah so that's done done
um this world trade space transform is
not gonna be the thing the case anymore
we still need to scale the text though
but that should be okay
um how do we do it in here so we
obviously set a font to size so again we
need to look at the runtime layout
and then look at how we do text or
whatever
so we do draw a string
um
and we just pass in a Scale Matrix I
guess we try to translate
oh it's Shadows I want to add Shadows
like because that might make text way
more readable
I probably should do that yeah I'll do
that as well
um but anyway
uh so how do we what do we do here so
it's it's transform which is
yeah to translate by that and we can
just take those in from the thing and
then we scale so I guess we need to
build up a transform Matrix ourselves
which should be okay
um
so we'll have this
and we'll have this
the scale it can just use from the scale
though
well actually Nara we can just use the
transform that is provided right like
that should just work so we won't worry
about the world transform
um because that would be weird I think
I mean we could worry about it
but I really want to
um I think we just do the transform
component
get transformed basically
uh
uh everything else stays the same I
think
um and then we can do this little uh if
Shadow situation
um we can add a shadow offset but do we
have to do that before we do the
because I don't know if I can do that
after we do rotation and scale probably
not
that's a bit annoying
um anyway this probably should just work
uh we just need to make sure that we
also do this
we basically need to just make sure
unfortunately we have some duplicated
code here
so let me just replace Maybe
the entire render 2D begins in
in all these areas
with that
that should be good hopefully I didn't
nuke stuff all right let's try this
first
there is still a technically there's
still a problem with this though like I
said it's not going to draw stuff on top
um but to do that yeah you'd basically
need like a different renderer with a
different pipeline which is okay
we'll not really a different part but I
just need to do it on top so you need to
use a different pipeline I might
do something like that
how does that work actually here though
doing a drawing it on top
um like as in do we specifically set
something up here that
is not
but I don't think we do so how do we get
it to be on top of everything
we just do external composite frame
buffer see this can this has the debt
this has the death buffer as well though
maybe that's just the fact that we have
it in
ah we just I think we can just make it
negative and if we make this that
negative it works with the orthographic
projection Matrix but not the other one
maybe that's a good trick
um all right let me fix this
yeah I ruined everything yeah I
shouldn't have done that
so what did this used to be
this so for the editor camera I guess
it's that
is this editor
what is a random simulation I think
that's also this
basically it's that
okay about three hours left
feeling pretty decent about that to be
honest
I mean there's going to be some
uh yeah that's my bad I think uh I'm
just assuming that that's there
um seeing serializer
we need to check to see if this is here
laughs
that's not a good thing
can we not do that
I think we do need a different scene
renderer to be completely honest we
probably need a specialized screen space
one which is good anyway
I think but it's because
um
yeah let's do that
uh so we'll do scene
um renderer and I don't know again this
might not
stay this way
but for now it's definitely the best
solution
I think
[Music]
all right and I wanted to do this if it
if it has green space entities
probably call this entities
um but let's do renderer
yeah so in this case we would have to
set the target frame buffer but the good
thing is we can set it to a different
one which for example doesn't have a
depth buffer and that would be better uh
probably but
let's try this anyway for now
I guess
I'm in line with
probably not going to change but
because we can't render lines but the
screen space under Earth moment as in
way just not doing it
um okay
is that good is that good
uh it looks like it
it looks like it yeah
okay let's um
so yeah this Block's definitely getting
replaced everywhere
um
so let's jump to the other areas
and then we need to also grab
uh that should be there it's just this I
think that's smart right
and is that all I did
why is this not a
H because I didn't rename it
and then that's in the wrong skirt
okay let's try that
yeah I don't know hopefully that'll work
okay well it launched um so now if we
just go to some text
basically the way I believe this should
work is I can type in like hello
and then you can see it's in World Space
by default but
if I check the screen space it looks
like it's gone but it's just very very
small so I think if I scale it up to
like
I don't know 50 50. yeah there it is see
uh and then I can use translation to
move it in terms of pixels
so that does mean I do have to do a bit
of my own math but you can see that
hello is just always now here now you
can see though it can be obstructed
though
um but I believe you can easily fix that
or maybe not easily but if I just move
the Zed
like if I if it's like minus really
anything I don't think it's possible to
obstruct it
so maybe I'll just keep that behavior
and then you can see we have hello here
and it's like that's it it's always
there it doesn't matter
um it will it will move with this as
well
but yeah but you have to know the
viewport size if you want to do and I
think you can also measure the string
maybe in pixels like the the if you want
to do layout stuff well we don't have a
layout system so you do have to do that
in in C sharp by yourself but obviously
you can do that now so that's done
basically as you can see
um that seems to work
um okay I wanna maybe quickly add the
shadow
just because I think we'll need that
so let's do let's do that quickly
but yeah you can see that was pretty
quick to add
components
um
let's just do float shadow
distance maybe I guess I can have a
bullying for it
so we'll add two new parameters
go to serializer might as well
all right
um and then let's say in a hierarchy
panel
okay done I think uh
okay so yeah so I don't know man like
that
I don't know if I can just translate
um and what am I doing during this
Shadow second riot yeah okay so let's
just build it up again I guess
uh let's just steal it from
the scene or the runtime layout
basically it's supposed to do that
um
yeah
so Shadow offset is
the shadow distance
uh
what what I call it
it is Shadow distance it's just a bit
correct yeah
the scale
scale is a bit
silly
translation
so that should be okay I don't know if
this is the probably not the most
optimal way to do it but I don't want to
think too hard right now
and scale
is that because I am constructing a few
matrices which I could probably avoid
but whatever it is what it is uh our
scale we have actually it's just in the
transform component I will use that one
that why it's a bit more
and basically it is what we want
but we use this transform
uh okay good so that's it right
um
so let's
basically add that and the other areas
let's get F5
uh yes Peter Peter wants a call
everything's okay let me stop the music
and then we'll go on a call
all right what's up
um all right I tweaked the I made a push
oh
um
correct okay
oh okay
um however uh
we need some way of indicating
[Music]
a sound
yeah I see it man
yeah yeah yep okay so uh can you is that
gonna be easy for me to add like as in
have you set up the logic for that I
just need the sound or
uh pretty much
um
[Music]
okay cool I'm probably not gonna do the
decorations because I think it's it's
more important right now for us to just
play test and get the game feeling yeah
better in terms of like the gameplay
yeah
cool sure I've added um screen space
text by the way
uh and even with a drop shadow
fancy so I'll I I guess I'll be the one
using it um so I won't bother explaining
to you how it works
um but yeah that should be good
all right cool
yep anything else I'll call you if
there's anything else so basically like
to summarize because I'm half asleep uh
you just need a sound effects like for
the compass number that's it
indicating that you cannot use the
compass right now and that was the sole
reason of your call yeah
yes okay good like I'm just making sure
I didn't miss anything because I'm also
programming while talking to you all
right cool yeah all right yeah
all right I'm back
we are back
um
no no
must have made a little typo somewhere
yeah it's called I didn't rename this
you know I miss it somewhere
instead of think
oh Shadow color I didn't said that
all right let's quickly do that
we'll make it Black by default with
Alpha
kind of like this though it's a good
little
thing
uh now how do I how does a let's maybe
copy the color because that's probably
gonna do
UI property color it's a little bit
different
um and also by the way if there is no
drop shadow like we shouldn't do this we
shouldn't show the UI so I'll just hide
the UI
all right so Shadow color
yeah and that's it I think
and then now for the same serializer
where's this music we are all Stardust
left behind
next level
[Music]
we are not all one ahead of one
uh okay
so we need to use the
um
the shadow color please
how is the pre-process of the worst
thing to happen sequence Plus
how would you live without it
just under three hours left feeling the
pressure now no I think I'm too tired to
feel the pressure
I'm pretty okay to be honest I'm looking
for yarn I'm looking forward to Tim
uh we're gonna do our post lavender
Mexican burrito
we should do that
what
I might have a solo burrito
all right let's see here
[Music]
we are we
oh I forgot to set the Zed
for the shadow it's going to be kind of
clipping
um
yeah so does that it needs to be around
an option I'm pretty sure but the Zed
should be offset uh by a little bit and
I think
what do I do insane what do I do in
runtime layout
I guess I should save the scene so that
I don't have to remake that Hollow text
every single time
okay done
um
[Music]
it was offset by like .01 I think
so subtract point zero one
okay oh I have to do that everywhere
whoops
of course I do
yes we use jolt instead of Nvidia
physics now well technically I think we
support both well at least partially
there's still an option though
well that's stupid
yeah but that's not that's yeah
ah that maybe yeah
thanks supervr for the Super Chat uh Ray
lib
um yeah I think so like I have you I
haven't really used it I've just looked
through it a little bit and it seems
okay where's my shadow man
that's weird
that just flat out
doesn't render my shadow now
why
uh it might be the
well actually no that kind of makes
sense
I think it's because it's out of bounds
but look why
why is it still in front
is this a different no it shouldn't be
uh I think it might be flipped compared
to that's weird though I'm a little bit
sussed about that because it's different
in the run time for the runtime layer
but I don't know
ah man yeah that's difficult
what was the reason to use jolt instead
of physics uh Peter could probably speak
a lot to that but basically it's a lot
faster
and it's also a lot
why is my channel is fine I think my
Shadow's not there because I didn't uh
I'm out of
still aren't there
yeah what oh that is there oh but it's
getting clipped or something
what the heck man
yeah I guess this is just in the
completely different order
somehow
it's like in reverse
oh that's so weird
does your engine actually have a GUI
library for UI intensive games uh not
really like we don't really have a UI
Library like we can render
UI elements like Sprites and texts and
all that stuff but we don't have we
don't quite have a layout system yet
all right well there we go there's your
text with shadow
um
and
yeah I mean you can
make it more dramatic
you can change the color of the Shadow
um
yeah cool
so
did we hire professional designer
designs I don't know
um
uh yeah Jay did that he's uh actually
the audio guy for Hazel um he just
really likes UI as well so shout out to
Jay for
making the editor look like this
um but yeah it's kind of based off of
unreal but he's just spent a lot of time
you know making Shadows for elements and
just yeah doing a lot of stuff
all right so I kind of wanted to do the
tutorial text I guess
um
so how does the game like is that
there's probably a main menu scene right
so this is supposedly uh this this font
man
are we how upset are we on this font
Tim
it sucks
oh look at it do you guys like this font
yeah but it looks it just looks really
cheesy
um good thing I can redo this uh text
with screen space text now though
which means I can do it another drop
shadow maybe look better
um
should I do that in play mode Maybe
I guess it doesn't matter
uh one thing is annoying about screen
space text though is it will um
it will render in uh
like one thing that's bad is it will
render all the time in the edit and you
won't be able to see past it so that
kind of sucks
um
what
ah okay I won't do anything I I just
kind of wanted to see how it works
no not no nice slip
yeah that should take two seconds anyway
um all right how do I go back
like I am okay cool
all right so should we have anything
um
should we have
also is that something off
uh
uh should we have like I'm just thinking
about the tutorial so we jump in and
it's like
okay so I guess we can
what's annoying is we can't easily
Center the text
we'd have to kind of measure it
and then you know find the middle point
I mean I don't know if that's worth
adding
uh I guess I just won't you know what
yeah let's just not Center it let's just
put it up like
but this also is going to depend on the
resolution you played at obviously
otherwise we'll just go off so we need
to get the we'll have something that
sets it up
um
Let's uh make it minus one I guess
I got okay
so you could maybe have your tutorials
hit there why am I already getting shot
though this is bad I don't want these
guys to spawn immediately
hahaha
and like I could uh so I want to reduce
the
you know out for a bit
and then I was gonna maybe I don't know
yeah Sprites are not screen space either
because I was gonna say I could do a
backdrop for it as well
we I can't even do around the corners
though so I don't know if that's worth
it but basically
you know if there was something that was
kind of like
behind it
you know like this for example
maybe be nice to like show the pop-up
like that
you know and kind of be like
this is the thing instead of just text
but I think we just don't do that
foreign
okay
I guess we can just
uh wow
because let's create the car crash not a
situation okay we won't do this
um all right so basically
okay component text component
okay so we can just hit the text is
there anything we want um but I'll
probably like
do it do a kind of a transition
actually why don't we just do like a
text queue
okay
uh five seconds maybe the default
can you do things like this or us yeah
you can I thought maybe it was for
properties all right so this is pretty
simple
um
uh we basically
need a Time
so
um
foreign
because we can pop from the front of it
how do you what's it q and C sharp
it's I think it's fine no
[Music]
apparently that should work
it might be um the city shop library or
whatever this way that doesn't have that
though
okay whatever we'll still use the list
and not the best but whatever
okay so we'll always get the first
element
um
uh text or text
uh
this isn't quite uh correct because we
need to
probably have a Fade Out fade in Fade
Out
so
uh
sorry not taxable current time text Dot
time
and then what are we doing so
um
basically I guess
if we need to
yeah but then we have to go back don't
we
do this
foreign
we could have like an animation state
but I just don't know if that I [__]
get around with
not doing that
yeah so well first of all I'm going to
depend on this so uh
I guess I will maybe
um
[Music]
I guess we can do this
foreign
[Music]
okay
um right so what am I trying to do here
so as soon as this happens yeah we need
to basically be like hey yo fade
Direction
uh is going to be minus right
we reset the current tax time as well
and that's going to go back up and yeah
we should probably set animation to true
I don't know if we really need that but
whatever I could just use yeah whatever
all right animation true uh We've
removed it
um I don't know if we can I guess we can
remove it though because it's not going
to change this yet that's the whole
point
and so basically
we can only
if like if
but then when we reach I guess when we
reach zero so if we're animating
um our opacity
this sucks I don't know like I'm not
again I'm doing this stuff in the
morning when I don't understand anything
um it's probably too complex now but
whatever uh opacity lessons less than
equal to zero that means that
I guess we're ready to go to the next
one right
yeah we could just do that here though
to be honest
so we trigger it here
we this basically is us going to next
next in queue by removing this
uh
and obviously this only happens that if
that happens but we can change the fade
direction to be positive
I mean this kind of triggers it but
so the next frame opacity will not be
zero anymore probably
make sure we clamp it though
uh and then we're gonna go back up
thanks power Kai for the uh
chat and the hahaha
I don't know if you're happy or not but
thank you
for the donation
um
so
all right what was I doing here so yeah
opacity is zero uh we go yeah whatever
and now we're going to
if we have another one if we don't then
it just kind of stays I guess at this
the animation will be true so actually
we'll be animating
which is a bit annoying
yeah man I don't know this was gonna be
simple I know it was just complicated
for some reason
um
oh
but no I mean it will be true if it will
still do this and I guess it will be
true if so that's yeah going that way
maybe this maybe this will work I don't
know I doubt it but I can try it out
um so if we're going to like play a root
motion player or whatever
let's do
thank you
I want to do them on create because I
don't know if I can
probably can't
um
foreign
[Music]
okay well that did nothing
oh I didn't uh notice
that
still did nothing
nice
man it should have done that though
because it should have said the text
so I don't really see why that didn't
work
uh
yeah I had a feeling I did that
okay so there's test it'll stay up for
maybe five seconds and then
maybe it'll go away or it will just stay
forever
oh no it just it that did work it's just
that it
didn't stop incrementing the alpha
that's funny it's
we should have clamped it to one that's
probably the only thing really
um
yeah
all right so now basically the idea is
with my little system is that if I go
into here
and I'm like
you know let's just add
LOL another one let's do a two second
one
I can just add a bunch of text to the
queue and maybe if I'm lucky it will
work
I'll probably not
that seems to work I can't believe that
worked yeah and you can set different
times for it wow okay I'm actually
really impressed that worked I'm like
surprised that impressed but yeah it's a
long one
should go about now yeah
sweet well there you go now we can queue
up text
which is cool
uh all right
so
I don't know if it's necessarily going
to be what we want to do because maybe
like certain regions Trigger text
instead
but I feel like it's nice to have
something like that
um so if we go to like level uh starting
to level player root version player
what happened here nothing
um then yeah I can be like uh you know
wsd to move
space to jump
uh
he to pick up
or maybe I should do
left click to shoot
right click to aim
maybe three seconds is enough
because it's already 12 seconds worth of
stuff
I don't know on the other hand we
instead of showing this stuff
you know we could
we could basically just
I don't think yeah I don't think we
should do that I mean was did a move
like we can probably show that in the
main menu and then instead what I'd like
to do is instead of the controls I think
I'd like to be like
foreign
I feel like this should be I'll probably
change the font but I feel like this
should be
and also I can do a new line I think
but uh what I was going to say is I'd
like to be able to set the size I think
um
so that's the time and then the the font
size because it might differ so I might
want to have it at 30 for this and
sometimes I might want it bigger
so if I just add that
um
that should be easy to do as well
uh font size just make a 50 by default
for no reason but basically I should
just be able to do
um I just need the the transform
component basically oh no I don't even I
don't even I can just do translation
so let's do
you know translation equals oh sorry
scale equals new vector
three
text of font size
and so I should have smaller font yeah
okay why does that
where I put the did I put the new line
in the other one
what there's no new line here uh is that
just because of the max width
so we can make the max width like you
know a lot more
yeah incoming radio transmitter that's
probably too small
and then
so maybe 50 was oh because it was a
hundred by default I thought it was 50
by default
yeah
and maybe a color could be good like we
could make that red I'm sending
everything to this
but I believe the boys should be doing
everything else
should be okay
foreign
fifty minutes but I kind of have to do a
bit of audio but not too much like
hopefully that'll be quick because I
don't think I'm gonna do any music
I would like to but
no time
uh okay so now we can set the color
as well
so like for example I can make this one
red
0.9
0.2.2 or something I don't know
and one so this one's opaque
and see this one will be white so if
that works whoops that's a compile error
felt proud of a color something wrong
with it it must be a part-time constant
really
all right well whatever
that just means that we do it the
old-fashioned way
which is basically without
parameters
but that doesn't mean this has to be
here
foreign
the main scene was called
that's weird
that doesn't usually happen
no it happened again oh that's just the
wrong scene I think it's supposed to be
called my menu that's just a broken
scene Maybe
it's good
yeah main menu I don't know what main
scene is uh so Saving Private Chino so I
guess we're privacino
by the way yeah that was just a name I
came
well because it's about coffee
because his name is private coffee
because he's the coffee guy
well so what do you want to call it
why Chino
uh well Australia let's call him private
chain I don't really care privacino
the reason why I'm asking is because I'm
gonna the radio transmission's gonna say
that
uh
I think I can just do
um at and then
write it out normally
all right let me just make sure that
actually works
nice uh the reason that's there is
because Carriage returns I don't think
are used uh we can make them work though
quickly
I'm guessing that's why at least
let's just do that
that probably will work
cappuccino oh yeah
that's not bad
saving cappuccino
captain or Saving Captain saving
cappuccino
yeah like a pirate or whatever but yeah
that could work
what
how's that possible
is it not a carriage return is it
something else
all right is this just not the only
drawstring function it is
that's strange
uh
let's see quickly I don't know I'm in
the release not oh tabs
you're right there are tabs there aren't
there
what's the character yeah it's a tab I'm
glad that showed up and release yeah
you're right thanks all right so tabs uh
we can just avoid tabs I guess
like I didn't mean to put tabs in
oops
let's make
it what oh what's that then
there's still something at the end of it
that's a bit weird
I don't know what it could be
but it's okay we don't have to guess
we can just put no no
it's too late
I mean obviously we could just wait what
what
did that not show up
I was gonna say we could just like
you know cut that out of release build
so we just skip the character if we
don't see it if we don't find it that
might just be quicker but
it's nice to know
there was a question mark in the uh
empty lines are fine
levels are just new line characters
okay so that that question mark then has
to be something different
but the only time we put in the question
mark is here I just took that out
what
oh wait it's down here as well actually
oh it's here what's that
ah
I think I know why
okay whatever
yeah the text is very messy like the
rendering for it because I'm pretty sure
the first pass is metrics and the second
pass is rendering and that's why maybe
[Music]
let's take it down
okay
make this one a bit smaller
I don't know why it is the best color as
well but whatever
um
uh this should stay up for like a good I
don't know 10 seconds probably
attention Frappuccino is this long
enough to read it the general has
ordered a coffee and needed that press
tab to open your compass use now I guess
that's not enough time pick up the
General's coffee order from Koi
temperature
I guess maybe like 20 seconds 30 seconds
I don't know
well you could always have a press
a press blah blah to dismiss
button so I could make it like
yeah in fact maybe we should have this
be manually dismissed
yeah actually why not just have a skip
if uh um uh if input dot is
key pressed so what key you should skip
and I guess
that's not used for anything I think
and this will only fire once per press
so
so what would that do that would
basically uh I guess you could do you
could just set current text time
to
um
this basically to text on time so
uh
if dot count greater than zero
yeah so now you can skip it
um
so I'll make it last like a full minute
then
because it's pretty outshore anyway and
if you press uh
answer on any message it will skip
whoa that's the font size not the time
uh
I guess the fade should maybe be a
delivery private we're counting on you
okay
I think that was just me
yeah so I can press enter to close
all right cool
uh great
um
is that cool that's cool I think what
was I gonna uh delivery
I'm gonna capitalize that because it's
the same
yeah I guess that's good uh What Was I
gonna do though oh the font
um to be honest I might just use like
like there is um
the font that we use for like them our
mono spaced font which is like source
code Pro or something
I could just use that
yeah I might use that and like bold or
whatever
let's see what it looks like with that
oh we could use that typewriter font as
well but I feel like this might look
better
this is kind of nice and then you guys
press enter to close
foreign
[Music]
I'm not that
what do you guys think for the message
which font
I think I should be able to switch them
live like this
yeah this one
or this one I I don't know this this
one's just a little hard to read maybe a
different typewritathon would have been
better but
like I just feel like this is a bit
cleaner
I don't know it could be a different one
entirely
so this is source code Pro and this is
veteran typewriter
I don't know I just don't like this
aesthetic it looks kind of
cheap
and the red text looks weird I could
tweak that
like then I could take the color a bit
depends where you look though because it
doesn't have a shadow
uh actually with this right
yeah maybe this would be a better color
so that's 255 179
zero so it's like 0.6 1.60
frame though uh
let's do 1.6
zero or something
so that's that color
veteran needs background to be more
readable yeah
go with this one
that's definitely readable I think
I don't know yet
I guess the name like
saving cappuccino
I don't know
well but I'm addressing it as private
Chino here but I can change that easily
but
it's just because it's ah I like the
private because it's Saving Private Ryan
yeah like that makes sense
and I and was there a reason why no
there's no reason
like I can just do this you know
wait but you spelled China with a CH
ah did I
think maybe it should be a double C
yeah I did
uh maybe it should be that no that's
weird isn't it all right fine
and maybe I can he'll address it as
Captain and then here it'll be Captain
but here will be Captain Chino but you
can call the game Captain if you want
well no we're actually called the game
Saving Captain Chino
Captain is like a little play on wire
cap play on whatever that happens there
I think
so let's
so generally sort of coffee I'm going to
try and play a Ned's stat I guess I'll
capitalize that
uh
to have to open your compass okay I use
it to navigate
so obviously red is up
so right is North so it's telling me to
go here apparently okay cool oh look
there's coffee I noticed the coffee
um
uh
maybe when you enter here it should
suppress that to close
maybe when you enter here it should push
a new message
to you
right
um
that will tell you like hey you can pick
up stuff
um
also like so P so this trash tax here
right which is where
on the camera so pick up prompt I think
is what it is
right yeah pick up prompt so let's make
pickup prompt
uh let's make it screen space
um
maybe like 80.
we'll do a different text as well but
80.
source code Pro
I could actually play with the kerning
bigger though
it should probably say the key as well
um no let's keep it zero
uh the color can be like a little either
gray and maybe we want
a shadow
that's not bad I think
oh and obviously the layout though
or the location
[Music]
uh in a second
but I guess I'll try and copy this
because it needs to be applied to here
yeah that worked and then I just made
the translation
160 minus one
eighty eighty eighty
oh it stays with that apparently that's
good wait why
ah
this is what it does
I mean this should probably clear the
text or something
in the oncreate function
it's probably too big
give me one second just fixing the
pickup prompts
how much time we have two hours good
uh
where's the pickup
okay so now if you go here
okay good
I'll send a little screenshot
yeah we're better this time
all right I'm gonna get on the court
here I'm gonna do the call on on this
computer all right so that stream can
hear
I'll be considerate all right uh you can
head over there if you uh
what's that sound oh it's the ambience
it's the game sound
why can't I all right
all right what's up
fixed the empties
the enemies
excellent
so first of all the player can actually
aim relatively well now it's still not
perfect but it's like you can actually
shoot enemies that are slightly below
you cool so like I should well
um
I don't know
like it's still not perfect like I said
yeah it's okay we can tweak that after
launch
yeah like I don't mind shipping this
yeah because I played it a bit
but um if I go up here the water still
does nothing as well
yeah but if I just start walking up this
hill now on the cheapest box that I
added for fun yeah yeah
um like on occasions it again not
perfect here either
but they can actually jump up tiles now
the enemies like that dude that's good
that dude was down there that's good
right yeah excellent I like it like it's
and it's terrifying because sometimes
you just see them coming over the hills
yeah that's yeah that's great
I love it it's like it's like they still
get stuck yeah that's all right you know
yeah because it's great that they have a
red dot on them sorry to interrupt you
but it's great that they have a red dot
on them because you can see them in the
distance and it's great yeah that
reminds me a little bit of forest though
this whole game this is Forest let's
just call it Forest two and call it a
day this is much better as well this is
Forest but there are no trees man
just jumping I can adjust
yeah no it's great also I entered the LD
games chat if you want to have a look I
sent the um
uh like what the UI looks like and I'm
really happy with it I think the pickup
gun I added e to it so it says so you
can see it
um yeah and it looks really good yeah
and it's all screen space and it will
never be obstructed by anything
uh which is great and also there's a
message kind of system where you can
just push messages from anywhere and
they'll show up for a given amount of
time or you can press enter to skip to
the next one
so it's it's flexible if we want to add
more text or whatever
but yeah so I feel like
levels like these where like there's a
lot of Hills I like them become a lot
more interesting now because yeah see
just because you're behind unplayable
[Laughter]
but I feel like they are as much cover
as they are in prison sometimes well
yeah well that yeah but the point is to
give you a slightly different experience
every time because if it's the same
exact thing I'm not saying anything yeah
that they can be a prison as well yeah
but I also gave the enemies like I
improved their aiming as well so they
can actually hit you a lot of like you
see I got hit there from quite a
distance yeah that's because the issue
was that there was no flickers were
coming out of their feet from the origin
yeah because they're they're Origins at
their feet ah that makes sense
um but
so I technically just all set it up by
like around their eyes yeah good yep so
they become a lot more accurate now does
it um does do you lose can you lose
uh if your coffee so hang on if I just
let them like shoot me enough
my coffee cup oh my God I'm gonna
probably get rid of this box yeah I
think we got it too much and therefore
you have nothing to give to the general
you get another reference exception oh
yeah nice why don't we just crash the
game if you get out of like coffee
because it's so bad
that thing if you shoot a general like
the game you lose you lose the game on
the spot
no oh you can treat the general because
you can yeah yeah
what's it called maybe I can quickly so
I think all we kind of need is
um what's it called I can make trees but
are you gonna be able to put them in the
game because you're doing something else
well no I'm not yeah I don't I don't
think so don't worry about the trays all
right Pete then I'll I'll have a look
because I'm free now I'll have a look at
adding the early uh whatever like end in
the game because you shot the general
thing
yeah I I was gonna say like yeah it's
really important to have that game
overstate obviously and like be able to
play the game again if you lose
um
yeah what else what's supposed to happen
is if you get shutting off your coffee
just runs out and the cup disappears The
Cup shadows and a new one should get
respawned at the original tent also you
can try again yeah
so oh that's good yeah I guess that's
good is it
but it's the same thing as restarting
but the thing is no no what I'm saying
is it's yeah uh the general yeah it's a
new generation that's true no this is
good this is good yeah
um I guess
what would happen is um
it should probably tell you though I can
just make a pop-up appear being like
go back and get another coffee or
whatever right
yeah
um
just gotta figure out why what's
Happening Here
I'm trying to find it so it failed to
actually place it
how many hours left uh like an hour 45
but then the submission hour so this
time because it's not our first let them
dare not that it was last time either
but
um we do not stop working until
submission hour like because before I'm
pretty sure in Forest we try to
basically ship the game when it ends
because
yeah so no
uh well that's great because again apart
from that game over message I'm
basically done with my tutorial text I
think yeah I'm not gonna dump like wa is
did like the controls are just going to
be displayed in the main menu screen
just do that well like I can add that or
you can add that whatever maybe I'll add
that later
um
oh it's already there in the main menu
okay well great that's great
um yeah in that case uh by the way we
probably never told you
experience
oh really wow because it makes no sense
without a stamina system because if then
you can just do it the whole time and
why wouldn't you so we just set it to a
speed that's slightly faster than it
would be nice to have a dash with a
cooldown
that would just kind of move you really
quickly for like a second or two just
because it's nice sometimes to be able
to dash away from enemies it just makes
it a bit more interesting I don't know
if I have time I might throw that in but
we'll see okay let me know it's not
vital yeah it'll be shift but yeah
response
what Hazel desperately needs is a volume
slider uh where sensitivity slider man
but actually this seems somehow okay
like it's in all of our sensitivities
are finding remember with Forest it was
weird I think we do it a bit differently
now but you still need it yeah
okay it can be in the launcher
so now you can see there is another cup
of coffee waiting for me
[Music]
compass and see that I need to go away
yeah I feel like the compass in certain
lighting conditions is really difficult
to like tell it's not should I fix the
texture real quick no just make a light
maybe you can make a light
uh on top of it
if you just add a point light to the top
of it or just make it a missive make it
a bit immersive that's your trick
but I'm serious that would that would be
right okay because that's easy in pity
you can just try it right right now
actually yeah
you can no you don't even have to stop
you could have just brought up play mode
I mean hit pause with the compass up and
then you might need to add textures they
might not be in Hazel ah
okay and now just go to the prefab go to
the prefab and check what material it
has if it's not a hazelnut it doesn't
look it's not
um I might change the amount of coffee
that you have
um
or increase the amount of coffee that
you lose because currently it's still
really like it still feels too easy to
just run directly to the General's end
great without fighting even though like
the enemies are more yeah
no also quickly before I forget
um why did you change it so enemies
spawn now in the around the starting
position
because they I specifically tried to
push them out
because I'd basically the idea is like
while the player is just new in the
world I don't want to immediately have
them be attacked by enemies they don't
even have a gun or anything
phone checked it will behave the way you
wanted to
I might have accidentally oh yes yeah
yeah yeah you need to that's okay good
yeah because otherwise it'll just
periodically spawn next to the player
which can happen later maybe when
they're getting closer to the tent but
it shouldn't happen immediately yeah
okay have you ever played the game at
all yet no
because sometimes it's annoying when
uh when you're dropping off the coffee
and then you're getting like the muscle
flashes on by default okay so it'll be
good if you did what you're doing here
with like the uh like generals turns as
well but maybe title or something like
that you know
I'm not so big about it yeah he has some
safety zone because sometimes you're
dropping off the coffee and there's
literally 10 enemies well you have to
kill them though that's the point
why would there be 10 enemies in there
no but now that this is off it shouldn't
be like that I don't know this is
beginner tent I'm talking about Journal
10. why would it matter no what that
does is it just spawns enemies
periodically just like press like just
that yeah yeah but they can
well of course they can but if you're
you know that if you're not fighting
anyone and you're just you know letting
uh enemies swarm you you're saying this
without having played it though right
my point is that if you that there's
going to be way less enemies now and the
idea is to kill them so therefore and
they're not gonna keep spawning
they'll only spawn if you go to new
chunks ah so basically you if you
actually kill them all you will be able
to get all the way to the enemy
General's tent with not a soul they're
not just going to keep appearing
stopping you from being able to hand the
coffee to the general
they're gonna stay dead
so
uh Peter maybe you you want to do this
on your end but uh you should probably
go to all the gun prefabs and just under
the muzzle flash just set visible to not
be checked by default
well just I mean I don't know but just
then like when I pick up guns it shows
it
okay you need to look at the prefab
all right you're doing it that way
yeah say it's there
yep
cool all right
um go through and then I will probably
push this yeah do you want me to push my
card first or
[Music]
yeah I've changed quite a bit just keep
in mind
oh and Peter's got I mean Tim's got
changes
I mean I haven't really changed that
many things like I've added stuff
so it should be okay because they're
just individual entities hopefully the
merge will be fine
so it seems like the only gun that
actually had the muscle
um flash was the assault rifle yeah cool
but yeah um you know what you can go
ahead and push because like okay okay
you can push because this is nothing
these are worthless yeah changes except
for that one yeah nice okay I'll oh
there's lots of stuff to pull as well
I last pulled it like seven a.m or
whatever okay I'm gonna try and then do
that
yeah
um okay cool
I'll see you later then
yep
okay I'm just gonna quickly go
your thing from uh dichotomy is super
nice what thing four lines of code that
I had to copy to get that nice like
transition effect oh yeah yeah yeah it's
it's nice it's quick all right
um I'll be right back guys
I'm just gonna go to the bathroom
[Music]
feeling like foreign
you know what I wanna do
[Music]
is
Christmas
[Music]
now maybe we can dance
foreign
[Music]
like
this
song name
is burning room Yeah by loving caliber
all right uh sweet so I want to add a
few more things but let's do the pull
first
foreign
I just pulled all your stuff and I'm
testing to make sure it works before I
push
foreign
I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna split this up
I guess I can reduce wherever I guess
everywhere to be consistent
[Music]
foreign
quicker
um
because a bit it's a bit annoying or
maybe it's not but either way if I just
do times two or something
I'll be twice as fast so half a second
I think that's better
I hope this is not too wide is this this
we could just reduce the font size as
well
because I'm just thinking if your
resolution is small that's not going to
care
um we have to make it do the height
thing uh as it not be too tall
um which I'll make that happen soon uh
let's maybe make it a bit smaller so the
size I think is 40. let's make it 30.
see how big that is
because it's still like readable
obviously yes
now
I think I want a little dot dot dot at
the start though to let it know that
it's not done
okay
right so
yes they're being the top thing uh I
think we can ask the scene what this
viewport size is right
not really
we have no no way to get the viewport
that's not great
it's pretty easy like if we can though
I thought I had that man script blue
uh scene.h viewport
selfie plus size get
width or something get people with
yeah get viewport width and get viewport
height like that is something that we
can get
oh it's application get with yeah I knew
it was there
okay so get yes application get with is
what it's called so that means that I
can just go into
the tutorial basically
and make sure that this text component
um so where is it at the moment
uh text
so it's at y 800 and how big is my
screen because that's a nice I like that
position so if I look at the scene
renderer and see the viewport size so
959 so it's 160 pixels from there so all
I have to do or all I should have to do
right because at the moment if I hit
play and if I like resize this you can
see if it's too wide it goes off the
screen
right and I'm gonna fix that
by
um setting
and you can resize I guess which matters
maybe but
I guess I can I can do text component
um or other translation
dot y
equals application
dot uh with a high rather minus 160.
and of course I can't do it that way
should make something to make that
kind of stuff possible
all right so now check that out it stays
constant
sorry size
which is good
doesn't matter if I'm playing obviously
if you're too wide it's just not going
to fit
it could be a percentage
as well
obviously like
I don't know maybe that's better anyway
this is silly obviously I should
probably stop this I need to make I've
got an hour and a half to make some
audio
but um but I'm done basically I think
after this so that's good
uh so let's do
foreign
sixty so 160 out of that is like 0.16 so
if I just do uh
um
that minus that times
0.16 that should scale well I think
so see now it kind of just goes up a bit
like that
just making the text I'm very bright oh
yeah that does happen sometimes oh Max
sample okay I thought I fixed that
that won't be a problem though that's
only if you resize it no no well if you
keep resizing the window but you can't
because we'll make it full screen and
lock it to that well it always says that
yeah but that that that's a post that's
an easy fix post thing
okay
I'm gonna do audio now why is it
rebuilding everything
yep
foreign
Hollywood
yeah I'm just added
well I don't even see them
the point is Jan just added the solution
to the problem
yeah he's
he's often oh that has to be changed
I'm about to tell Peter I'm a battle
push and when I do I want everyone to
pull so that we're on the same page
I should test that in the run time as
well maybe
whatever
problem will fix it
okay I've pushed guys uh but you need an
engine pull as well
all right I'm about to do audio which
I'm going to probably do on a different
computer
house
[Music]
foreign
I'll wait for you
[Music]
it's a beautiful
life
[Music]
tonight
waves
[Music]
under Blue Skies
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
instead of this break up
a place
[Music]
instead of this
week
[Music]
without any sleep
thank you
cool cool
[Music]
this morning
the 17 days
[Music]
thank you
um I don't know if I'm gonna really show
me making audio
just because you guys weren't here I'm
going to be using headphones but if you
want I can
just have the mic this mic kind of up a
bit any interesting bug what happened
my gun got flipped all of a sudden yes
yeah because like I I haven't had that
until now and then I pick up another gun
and it flips back into the right
position I think don't worry about it
just we can fix it after launch
yeah because I'm not like if it's not
even something that's easily reducible
that's not great I've got bugs like that
and that particular stuff
um okay let's Okay uh I want to start
recording audio so you guys need to be
quiet
yeah but also maybe don't talk at all
times yeah uh can you show me how to do
the screen space
if you just
oh yeah you just make a text component
press create space and then the
translation is it and scales in pixel
space okay
um so in other words this will have to
be in pixels yeah X and Y is that you'll
have to set to minus one okay
okay uh and then scale is the font size
let's go so try and give it uniform yeah
I'll just yeah I'll just do
my I'll use my voice
man I just put that away
foreign
tell me a keyboard is so loud
man I just put that away
foreign
voice I'm pitch shifting it down a bit
so it sounds kind of funny but
uh yeah
I think the more voices like that the
better the game will be and we could
detect how far away I am from the tent
and be like almost there
that's pretty cool yeah there's lots you
can do yeah now when you get into stuff
like that it's really cool
um
kind of sucks how
uh Hazel doesn't support more than one
fonts at the same time you know what in
a scene
you can't have two phones two different
this has been a bug since like Space
Invaders I've told you back then like um
the phone just starts glitching out
like the glyphs just get wrong
because for the for the ammo counter I
don't really want to have 10 or 25 I
wanna just have like the letter I yeah
you know and then but this one has like
no I'm still gonna do a letter I with
this one I think it's whatever
foreign
huh
I'm spilling it damn it
damn I'm spilling it
stupid
I think
I think this is the right direction I
I think the General's tent is this way
I think this is the way to the journal's
tent I I think this is the way to the
General's tent
almost there
foreign
okay
thank you
foreign
done
kind of
I would do more Bob
not okay yep
um all right
so
let's get it all in here
here they are this is what I recorded
ah I'm not showing my screen whoops
these guys
uh let's see if there's any check
changes
approved enemy jumping
all right so
better your life ammo let me pull this
stuff
is there anything out probably not
nope all right come
uh I'm about to push again
don't have time
oh that's smart
someone said it based on the percentage
of coffee you deliver you should get a
score
okay
let's start with
the uh
maybe the footsteps
no I can't hear that for some reason
is that because OG files don't play
that would be a blunder
it might be a bug
can't really hear that either
what
hey
um what's it called how does a compass
work this used to work
what happened here but
it's my audio not work no that works
what do I have to build the sound Bank
probably not
but this used to work
it's very weird
yeah so that works here
and uh I mean as soon as he's born in
you should be able to click Tab and see
the comments but not here
great
okay what's your child of the compass
entry called
uh but it's it doesn't make any sense
it was working before oh look
is that it
what is it called uh
because
the point to your media objective so
that's really strange
the invalid sound thing might be
who this is it very slow to rotate no
that's not printing there
what
happened man
yeah it should be the right looks like
it's loading the right audio device
okay that works now so basically if I go
to this one
it just breaks everything to the point
where
if I go back this doesn't play anymore
all right great I'm gonna try re-export
them as wav files
OG should work but apparently not
you drop a coffee right next to you and
the arrow will go from pointing at the
center points into the a lot of pay to
do to my arrow I don't know
immediately for me it takes like forever
to turn around
yeah I mean I don't know because now
it's working fine
so I don't know what that was and never
mind that disregard that uh what's it
called I'm about to push
um
a new Compass material double check that
after this push the company still works
okay I got some new ones
I didn't do all of them I'm just gonna
see if this works
unfortunately that's very weird
oh but now there's two of them
well that one works yeah so it's an arc
file issue okay
so we'll remove the odds for now
maybe later we'll fix it and push it
because it will be smaller
okay
now uh attenuation probably not for
footsteps
foreign
follow this
I think that's just the source not the
which is unfortunate
um all right so let's try and make the
footsteps work because I need to make
sure I can trigger stuff
so
and I forgot how to do that
I'm probably gonna have to look up
dichotomous code actually
to see how we did that
something something audio play Move
audio
where's that that's in I think that's in
player base
okay so audio post event new audio
command that and then it
it's that audio component I think
so let's try something like this
um
I mean I never got around to fix and so
you can't shoot your in general
ah I
mean I should because although I did
upgrade
okay
very hacky very last minute
uh
I should did the Epsilon thing shouldn't
we
um
here we can use that
yeah
why was that showing up for you
it's no scented
but the thing is it is for me
um and
yeah I'm gonna fix that why can't I I
guess I have to make it const
all right let's try this
27 minutes left
left nice
um okay so play out yeah needs to have
an audio component
um
and we need to add an audio event
called footstep that's just one full
step
play
my footstep
please work
excellent that's probably too much of a
delay though
and I'll make it quiet I think
but I'm really happy that that just
works
because I don't have time to deal with
it
um
oh it doesn't stop
playing
uh well if it's
I think if if this is too much it'll
accumulate
see
but also why is it still playing that
doesn't make sense
that is something weird
oh or
no wait what am I doing if these are
either of these are false is what I
think I want right
that doesn't work at all though
is that because my dead zone is
not correct
well narc because it would be playing
I could just be like if animation
doesn't equal one as well because that's
just the idle animation right
but that doesn't work
why
I guess I can debug
huh well it's not hitting that
what
this stuff isn't one
so shouldn't that mean if I'm like
walking what the heck
that's weird
that's really weird
okay somehow didn't crash
it's not printing animation doesn't
equal one
what
or is that is this explicitly for the
controller
oh it is ah damn it
funny
I guess I can do it last so that's me
right for just sticking code in the
middle of a function
I might I might make it a little bit
more delayed
although no I think I think that's okay
maybe I could randomize the Audio I
don't know
um I'll make it quieter as well because
that is too loud
now's not the time to tweak this
although I don't know is that just
annoying like why even have footsteps
I don't know
yeah I guess if they're quiet and subtle
they're fine
okay now I have to go through and make
all the other ones
uh I didn't put all them in I think
okay so Peter wanted a a buzz
um I removed when jumping yeah that's a
good idea
and maybe if
and not targeting it's all got more
remover for that
and
okay
I don't know whether
oh here it is
there's a um
there's a is grounded
yeah that's good
all right
so if press that I can't use Compass
right now so this is where we do the
um
audio playing
I can't use Compass all right so
um
yes yes nice comment by Peter it's very
helpful
um
so basically
uh bars
and then maybe we can do a
random
like we can do a
let's see
so zero to
I don't know 10.
equals like three I don't know
I want to be like
no no I just wanted to I just put that
away
um
so it always plays a buzz and then
either no or like a 30 chance or
whatever I've known or one in a 10
chance if I just put that away
so I need I need this now
um let's set up the sound configs first
just put that
away all right by
have them all here
no no it's just maybe like um
oh yeah I should have that
no
[Music]
they're a Reverb uh wait I just put that
away
man I just put that away
as well a little bit of Reverb
s
because I need to minus half back
basically because the the origin is
right on on the first letter
that's why it's all
unable to find trigger command
beautiful did I misspell it or something
oh buzz buzz isn't a thing
I forgot the buzz
or whatever
like that
we can pitch it down a bit I did Pitch
it down in the thing
we need gunfire as well I don't know
time for all of this
because that's scalable
um
okay the Reverb is a bit silly or at
least that much
it's silly
make this a bit quieter
I just put that away
okay that's good enough
um
there's a little bit of static the first
time there's players so
maybe it shows start text could do that
okay so the X with
196.90
wait
that should sound more staticky but
whatever I don't care
do like a little bit of a larpass
on it there
take out some of that high end uh
strike
stay incoming radio transmission
basically yeah
yeah uh I needed to fix the text thing
yeah
tutorial
s
so I want to kind of set the text
component
dot text to be empty
that will clear that
um
and I think we could start with that as
well
all right
I had the whole getting closer thing
which I might put in later
um
that's what I'm looking at
I'm going to go to that free sound place
these are all gonna be so bad aren't
they
that's not bad
for a High School production nice
that could be the shotgun one
I really should be having
using headphones because otherwise
that could be the sniper
no some of these are OG files okay we
won't use the solid one
because that doesn't seem to work
free sound I'll separate the ones that
aren't mine ah well I didn't have to do
it here but it doesn't matter
Source actually
I don't remember which one's a witch
um there'll be three different gun
sounds
I guess gunshots
so oh that's Source okay
um so let's do
see gunfire one
um
gone fire
two
let's see let me kind of fire sniper
Okay so
um
what's this one that was that sounds
like a shotgun
that's the sniper
okay that should be the default one I
guess
uh so let's let's leave that um we'll
make it specialized
I forget how to make that
sound good because I think it'll drop
off really quick
oh but there's a Min gain isn't there
an amendus and some max distance
whatever we'll see if that this works
um
give me a look at the shotgun
that's a sniper
I guess a little bit of a Reverb could
be cool for the sniper
okay
I don't know we'll see I I've really
figured out how to do how to set up
sounds properly
uh
I'm gonna fire one
well this can be like can't find a
shotgun actually gunfire
assault rifle
and gunfire sniper
I don't know why I chose to call them
gunfire but
that's okay
how much time 10 minutes nice
um
okay
so now we just trigger them
so when the player shoots
and we have to play them at a certain
location as well that's the thing if a
player it's okay but for enemy is a bit
different
um so what happens when we shoot
this has gone shoot
play sound and then I guess it'll depend
I'll play audio I guess it will depend
I guess it will depend where um
like what it uh is
um in terms of uh like the gun that
you're using will yeah determine that
but let's just do gunfire assault rifle
let's just make sure that works uh
there's a cool down anyway but
unable to find okay
um
gunfire assault rifle did I misspell
that
yes
yeah it's too quick
and also they get destroyed for some
reason
wonder why
oh that seems to like crash I think
or is it crashing
why is it printing me that thing
huh that's strange
what
ah because it overwrites the other one
maybe
why it does it
there's personal location which is good
does this actually
like
ah or is that just my weird
low pass or whatever it is specialized
let's turn that off
that's what it should sound no I didn't
do any filters
what
it's not what it's supposed to sound
like bro
why is that the case huh
and I mean there's a cooldown on the gun
isn't there
well not really on those stupid
particles man
on what
on what dichotomy did you like during
the economy you want to be like y'all I
want to make this into proper Jam yeah
well I and I don't know but remember we
wanted to at some point though often I
remember trying to convince him right
uh I really like my okay
yeah I don't know man
uh well actually I guess gun shoot has
the cooldown doesn't it
yeah
that's that's probably why
I don't even have access to play it
doesn't matter though because this is
might as well be static
oh no it's not because it needs the
audio component
um
uh I'm just gonna make a uh and I'm
gonna make this like a little
yeah
instance I think
I think
make this little Singleton
something like
that because I don't have time
and that's a lot better
but I guess you can't like the problem
was there before was that I mean I guess
we were playing every frame but it's
more so the fact that
um
like I don't know if that if I need
different or like I guess the way that
would work is every enemy would have
their own audio component right
and then they yeah I guess that would
work that's how it would work
so if we did audio component
for an enemy that works
um uh
what would we do
so
the enemy prefab
would get an audio component
someone can be destroyed was false
though
yeah let's just try that
and that's important because now
if we look at the player
uh it will do Post event at location
and the location is translation
so it's actually gonna this will be a
spatial audio which is cool
um
doesn't need the audio component uh this
might be different
a temporary audio object or maybe this
is good
I don't know we'll see if this works
but basically like it's gonna try and
shoot
right should cool down
okay so this is where it tries to shoot
I guess
and if it should cool down it returns so
we can try to play audio
uh here I guess but also the I mean the
gun is doing gun shoot so it might play
out
which is I think personally I think gun
shoot should return a bullying
and that way like
it can tell you whether or not the shoot
happened and so you can basically be
like yeah it should probably be here if
the shoot happened then play the sound
um
uh and same with this right because I
don't like the idea because otherwise
the gun does the playing which is a bit
weird and it has to do that so no single
thing anymore I guess
so shoot happens here
if shoot
uh then play audio
this can just be Global but the other
one's spatial so I don't know if this
will work I guess we'll find out
it's amazing how much better audio makes
it
it's really satisfying
here we go let's see if that works
oh
oh I made it non-spatial
uh and I guess the player but it does
play the sound that's important
so let's do our location as well
uh this is what we'll have to do as well
I think so translation I don't really
care about the rotation
let's just do Vector three dot up or
something I don't know
or well whatever
um but yeah we need to go into what time
is it two minutes left
we need to basically go into here
and just make this yeah Special again
okay
so now let's see if that works
it's a lot quieter
which is not good
let's see if the enemies work though
[Music]
yep that works
this is pretty sick
there's too many particles there
but yeah that's it like I don't know
it's rough
but it's done I think we just need to
combine it and build it and we've got a
minute left
and all the gun sounds at the moment are
the same but we can I've already made
all the gun sounds I can just probably
package it all up during submission now
I'm sure that's fine
but yeah that's it that's done
um
was that something I wanted to do I
wanted to reduce the amount of particles
I'm gonna have to add tearing for this
like particles maybe should be able to
be turned off but obviously we can do
that press launch
so we've got an hour to submit now
so we'll submit this build I guess and
then we'll obviously uh improve things
and fix bugs and whatever throughout the
day at least that's what I'm planning to
do
um
yeah the particles yeah
so that's the Sparks
so at the moment we spawn 10 of them
let's just do like four maybe
and with the blood like I don't know
I'm just I'm just a little bit concerned
about the performance
that's static's annoying as well I might
record that
and yeah the particles will be nice if
the particles were the color
oh I didn't do the thing that I wanted
to do
what the heck happened my mouse oh my
mouse died
Mike
what is the current deadline why that
why are there too there's a deadline for
work and there's a deadline for
submission so
uh oh you know what it is actually guys
um as in like why it's because the audio
listener should be on the player not on
um
the camera
so
let's remove this let's try let's see if
that makes it sound any better
that's not a special sound so that'll be
fine
maybe that should be yellow instead of
red oh look there's an enemy
definitely makes it sound louder
did I have a bit of Reverb on it
no I didn't let's add a little bit Tim
check this out
it's a bad world
where's my there it is
it's really nice having that compass
check this out Tim
he's busy
oh what
so
oh no that's that's really weird
why is that the case
that's really weird
it kind of seemed to work better when it
was on the camera to be honest
yeah let's I'm gonna put back on the
camera I don't have time to change to
play with it now
um
camera
oh that was on the actual camera as well
yeah this one
and I don't think it looks too dark
it's just I wish this was a little bit
louder like when the player shot versus
snot
but I think that the specialization
works properly
oh but see that's closer to it but I
guess it's right you're the camera kind
of
I just wish the player
I wish I could add a modifier to the
player and just make him louder you know
and that would be nice
um
you know I might be able to
yeah but there's no melee unfortunately
that kind of sucks doesn't it
forgot about that
um okay so play audio
can I at all
like tell it to play louder I don't
think so
I can do set parameter but it's for a
particular
yeah
oh no you know what I could do
I know how I could do it
um yeah it's easy I can just I'll make
another sound config
that isn't specialized basically and
since there's only one gunfire sound
can't fire
NS
we'll just call it gunfireness
and this will be the assault rifle or
whatever it's the source so it's I think
is it this one or the last one yeah the
last one oh well yeah we won't make it
specialized we'll still do like the
Reverb and we might make it a bit
quieter because I'm pretty sure it was
loud
um yeah and then we'll just do gunfire
assault rifle but I'll call it an s
non-specialized
and yeah
and so now the player specifically
can trigger that one
right
be nice to have some screen shaking
General polish but yeah all right done
okay what have you guys done that I need
to pull for submission
I might have a code chain but like what
because I did I've obviously got a lot
of changes nothing to the engineer
um so there'll be like a bunch of stuff
that I need to so prototyping make sure
it works
um I don't know what oh no conflicts
apparently that's a bit suss
did you guys add any files
what's it called are you ready to stop
building already well why not yeah
and I have to do the page and the build
like on the launcher oh
I'm gonna spend the rest of this day
probably just putting together like a
launcher with graphic settings with like
you know part how many particles do you
want
so you can actually pay like low
medium-high amount of particles or
whatever
and uh stuff like you know read me
setting up the website for it but it's
kind of cool I I've also got a bunch of
sound effects that I recorded I just
haven't had time to put in so I might
sneak those in without anyone noticing
right stream you won't tell anyone
I watch code change okay in five minutes
well yeah yeah I'm just gonna go through
this anyway oh that's cool the typing
foreign
does the shooting work no
my shooting's broken
what
all my audio events got nuked
what except for the ambience one how did
that happen huh
what the heck
why did all of my audio events get nuked
ah there's always all this dodgy stuff
with audio so I have to remake them now
why does that happen
I don't know it's a bug
alright so let's do let's yeah
which ones were there footstep
I I guess I can just search yeah it'd be
probably faster to just search for like
this
and then
I'm just gonna take a little screenshot
of this
keep it here and I can go through
everything
static
Buzz
yeah I don't know why like
that didn't work
this shouldn't take very long to fix but
but yeah
so the assault rifle is gunfire one
the NS version is
uh this one
I just put that away
static
I might reduce this at the
how loud the static is as well footstep
bars
and that's it so let's say that's not
that bad right as long as it actually
worked
Ah that's my bad I had my
spacebar on there
on the stop button
yeah my footsteps are working
guessing this will work
check the animes make sure they play
I definitely don't like the ammo
well look at it it's obnoxious
maybe I'll make it only when you fire
and also look it's not going down it's
because ah
that's specialized audio
more quiet than I would have liked well
I mean like I think we need to have an
ammo indicator of someone and it's
better than ammo equals 10 but do we
really need an ammo indicator like what
if you can't shoot you can't shoot
like what's the difference what are you
going to save your ammo no I think we
should have it but why tell me why
because most users are used to seeing an
ammo indicator why do we have to make a
game like most users
but I think we should have one because
like I remember I was playing it without
without the ammo being on screen because
it was just outside somewhere and I'm
like why the heck can't I shoot right
now oh maybe it should yeah just
disappear well yeah but that's why when
people play games and they can't shoot
they don't assume it's a bug
like for development yeah it's nice to
have have that just to make sure that
things are actually working well I'll
keep it I might just make it smaller
move it a bit and make it only like fade
away if you haven't shot for like five
seconds there's no reason to just I just
don't like the fact that it just
crowds the screen for no reason you know
um all right
I don't know if it was linear
exponential you can because you can play
with these and
might make it a bit better I have to
make sure I have time to submit
I did the thing again um yeah that's
right though I didn't want to make this
static
quieter
there is something weird with that
though
oh that guy just ran down
there's no death sound there's no place
now I made Earth sounds I just haven't
put them in
so I might put them in after submission
because I've already made them so um
that doesn't count as cheating right
um all right so
what's up
maybe clicking sound when you have ammo
yeah I'm out of time so maybe later
I can watch later in a different version
uh
I just wanted to quickly tweak the ammo
where is the ammo
is it on the gun
hey Tim where's the ammo
like in the level
where's the ammo in the level uh just
search for armored on the camera okay
but it's not it's just it's screen space
yeah yeah it's yeah because it doesn't
matter yep sure I'm just gonna play it
with it
no because
do it do it without the thing playing I
think I'm gonna do it here because it's
probably
well why I'll just copy it later because
I need to I need to see where it is
I could
probably don't need that maybe that
looks weird why is that not blending
though
oh because the shadow
maybe that's not obvious enough
how's that
uh and then I'll need to remember that
basically
wrong scene
okay
um
wait that's ammo account text that's the
wrong thing I was going to say
um
that's all right no
I hate how it moves stuff
uh okay so
that ammo thing
how does that actually get displayed
though
Hammer account text
yeah it's on the player
oh it is ammo context is it
Hammer account text
oh it is still is okay never mind so I
was right
okay good I guess yeah of course I even
saw the bars
yeah yes yep
so if it's greater than like five
uh we'll do nothing
uh otherwise we'll do
ammo right
when you pick up on your gun it should
show you
um so
foreign
s are like that though
like how do we pick up a gun
there's a gun pickup isn't there gun
item
on pickup
player controller okay
yeah so player controller dot let's just
do
time since last shot zero
and we'll just make that internal or
whatever
so that way it'll reset
yeah
all right cool uh why is it in the wrong
spot what happened to it
uh yeah it's supposed to be at 100 150.
uh I guess something moves it something
must move it
yeah because I think it used to have to
ah right because of this yeah no I'm not
doing that anymore
shh
and I put it up there
so that we can yeah so that's above that
I guess I can lower it a bit though
pause
I'm being a bit of a perfectionist but
I could set it to be like here
so it's above this coffee thing
and done so Tim you said there was one
more thing that I had to pull
okay
uh well okay well then regardless I'm
gonna just build the sound Bank
I'm going to build the Shader pack and I
want to build
the asset pack
scared of that
um cool done done these
so now
let me go about 40 minutes which is good
make sure the runtime actually works oh
it's probably gonna load the wrong scene
but it's okay
load the right scene
oh okay good
well then I might just focus on this
it's not that hard though but
oh what the audio doesn't work oh you
know what I think I know what it is and
I didn't commit it again it's me running
the runt no but that doesn't make sense
either
oh
uh what
but the first one works though
or do I have to save project is that why
maybe I didn't save the project
and so it just stores it in memory or
something ridiculous okay let me fix the
audio for like the tenth time
yeah I'm pretty sure it just doesn't
have my screenshot I do not
um I'm pretty sure
it just has to yeah I need to save the
project
so let me just redo these
again
and I'll save the project this time and
make sure
because I thought it it should really do
it automatically but
it does not alas
one two three four five six seven one
two three four five six seven okay
that's all of these ones
play buzz
play footstep
if it's just as simple as having the
project I'll be happy though
because that's not that's obviously easy
to fix
okay so I guess at the moment even if I
close it and hit Ctrl s
it still hasn't see there's still no
audio thing but if I hit
file safe project
then aha audio commands registry okay so
that's why that's yeah a little bit
weird
um but again
I'm just happy that it does in fact work
beautiful
all right yeah mouse sensitivity will
probably be controlled by launcher
um
yeah whatever
so that's done yeah save projects have
everything
I don't know if we need to rebuild the
outside pack probably not because
actually that far I don't think goes in
there
because our audio system is a little bit
separate still
I'll build a sound Bank just in case and
hopefully now I can just run the runtime
and it will be perfect still loads the
wrong scene but you can see it all works
like the audio works
okay
um
what's up
we've got 37 minutes to submit
um I mean it's like could really be
done
um like in terms of you know everything
uh I just need to work on yeah let's
actually make sure first of all we're
gonna do a try distribution build
outside of visual studio in a minute uh
yeah I need to build this as well but um
before I do that yeah maybe make sure
we're loading the right scene
because
what's like at the moment yeah it's
loading this
uh it should be loading
the main scene I'm guessing why are
there two of them man oh that's really
bad
um well actually we might be able to
uh look at the project settings
my main menu I see
tell Yan about what
when uh Peter completed the game instead
of taking him to the main menu like it
should uh it shouldn't with tutorial
taste again
and it didn't instead of taking it to
the main menu how what does that have to
do it and then he fixed it by picking up
the coffee club and dropping it again
and then
I don't know why that would happen
uh what happened here I guess that scene
doesn't exist or something
really is there another main scene
yeah I know her but they seem to have
multiple IDs
like as in there's multiple copies of
them in the asset registry for some
reason but to be honest I think we only
need two things for the game
yes uh no there's only one main menu
seen oh I'd copy the wrong
I must have copied the c-sharp script ID
ammo's not broken it well I don't think
it is it's just if you have above 10 it
just shows 10 right yeah so how much do
you start with
oh and look what's this
ah this doesn't do anything does it the
text yeah it doesn't all right but it
probably doesn't need to because it's
going to be what do you mean well this
is literally a 16 9 aspect ratio the
most common one okay this is a bit wider
because of that thing so that needs to
be fixed yeah
that's easy fix there
I need oh can you make an icon yeah
little icon
uh what should it be
I don't know like the economies one was
really cool I just it was like a little
square I guess it can be like the coffee
cup coffee cup yeah maybe the coffee cup
with likes I don't know and make it like
make it maybe 256 by 256 okay PNG and
I'll do the rest
okay so main menu
text
where is it
uh yeah where is it
UI
okay they're all kind of different
that's okay because I should be able to
just move it all like this
but unfortunately zero is there for some
reason
and H is there
nice
oh it's not screen space as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yep
I'll just remake it then entirely I
guess
yeah that one is
not this one well hopefully that one
will yeah oh no but see
uh so you have to click on controls yeah
I guess there's quite a lot of them
because I was thinking like just to
display them here but
no but like I mean is it clear to use
the arrows to even because people are
going to try clicking on these oh yeah
that's not gonna work
that should be like okay probably
yeah this one should be okay but this
one
is the problem one
why does that not crash for you for me
resize it like I literally I don't know
resize my viewport I don't know maybe
you guys I don't know yeah it's weird
I'm serious I haven't had like a single
Graphics crash during this whole Jam
I haven't even been working in Hazel and
I've had
well
Peter says resizing it for him also
questions
like he crashes just saying well how
though what's different with you guys
well I don't
know I should try outdating the drivers
I actually haven't milk
I I'm outdated because I remember like a
day before the games there was no
yeah
um all right let's make a new
okay so this will be set
programmatically
possibly too big
set at 100 well I think we'll set all of
these bounds kind of somewhat
programmatically
yeah but Dev doesn't have the new
renderer
um do we have a coffee particle here
like a what is it is it just a scale
Cube
and there's a breakup
ah it is literally called coffee
particle
I was staring at I was like what is it
called what do you mean what is it
called
I'm staring at only coffee acids you
know again
what do you think
okay that's not bad
oh this is still ah I forgot the minus
one
yeah
of course
Okay so
I think this is good but yeah now we
have to add some scripts to it though
so
foreign
maybe I can just get right through maybe
I can just be cool with it let's do like
a script
um
we'll call it I'll copy the tutorial one
we'll call it main menu
UI
we'll keep literally this
power control
well I mean
that's my menu it was uh controller
because I kind of I wrote the code but I
forgot to test it
that's right but caloric has a function
it's in the opposite direction because
we're going to go through find all of
the uh
things here
all right
that was awesome one of the scripts you
will sit in the attention to like 5.7
that's pretty high
um if uh root house component
text component
then
um
texts nice
yeah so that will just uh go through and
add basically at all the children I
think
um
and so the idea with that is when we
resize
so
laughs
this will be good to reuse later
probably don't need a ride at this good
now but
uh let's say you went
let's just make it ends
because back to two eyes in it
um
uh and then we'll basically recalculate
everything so we're going to go through
all the children or everything that we
have here
so for each text
um
and my plan was basically to just take
the existing
but it'd be good if we knew the factor
oh
maybe we could be cool and use rotation
for oh but it's going to be a
no no I think yeah I think I was gonna
be like tax original translation.x times
like 0.1 or something or 0.2 or whatever
might be too much
[Music]
um
so we'll basically do
wait what did I do
wait no so it's the it's X Plus
and then the percentage is also based on
this plus like that 0.2 or something
sorry uh the width 0.2
what is that does that make sense is
that gonna be weird
I don't know
that might I think that's gonna be weird
I don't think that's what I want
well that didn't do anything as well I
didn't
why did that on do anything
oh it worked perfectly
I actually think that thought that
didn't do anything but look it moves the
text
no no no I didn't it's the up and down
that's supposed to move the taxes and
that but no but either way this works so
I'm going to just ship it let's uh clear
let's get rid of this
um because I just realized that by
making it screen space I'm now uh making
this I know if you're wide enough then
obviously it's going to break
I guess that's bad if people are playing
on Ultra wide
it break
whatever
um okay
is that good enough do we just ship that
let's try and ship this
oh yes I'm out of samples maybe that's
the graphics crash they were talking
about which is not a big deal
that's fine
too bright
that's the run time
yeah let's just ship this out and then
we can we can actually fix text later
the important thing is to get that build
and ship it which I'm running out of
time to do
so we'll build the asset pack
okay that's better I guess so Ultra wide
setup
uh well I guess it's
that should be fine I think
yeah whatever it's good enough
um okay so in the runtime I want to do a
few things in a minute but I guess we'll
make it
be full screen we'll change it to be
called
saving
uh private or saving cup
Captain Chino
uh yeah we'll just do full screen true I
guess vsync true
oh and the graphic settings you'll be
able to change but I feel like I should
just ship it like this right
right hey um
oh no the that changes the text there
Ash yes yes background for the icon
yeah that's right because it makes it
big and stuff
um that's not great
where does that even happen
the main there's gonna be yeah main menu
I guess it's this one
oh that's so annoying but I guess we can
just
so selected scale
is that that's an absolute scale it's
not based off of
okay so what we're going to do is
that's so annoying well but it's only
for two options so actually we can I
think we'll just hard code it so
um I think that we can just do this
which is not great but so 80 because 80
is the scale so I think if I adjust the
quickest way would be basically uh
selected let's just make it 80.
times like 1.2 so it makes it a bit
bigger
and then deselected will be just times
like one right
that's done
uh and I want to actually add one more
thing
cool
what's that
here's ours I'll just say use r as an
enter
to select
oh they need to disappear
why does that suddenly not work
hey uh Tim yeah
um how does the uh how does this
disappear
what did you do to make it oh it was in
World space okay never mind yep sure
do we know if we're in the help section
how do we know
yeah
is there like an easy way to be like
you're on the help yeah literally I
think it's called on help screen but
that's just when transition starts yeah
is there a transition function it helps
brain transition beautiful that's all I
needed and it stays at one yeah
what do you mean
does it stay at one when it's on the
help screen this transition
yes okay because it's like dichotomy
yeah great yeah it's a code from there
yep okay
um because yeah what I need to do is
basically
uh
and what has the actual main menu
what has the main manuscript which
entity
okay
this sucks so annoying
oh but it's all of the screen space UI
isn't it
no control oh yes because controls is in
controls menu okay yeah it's just screen
space UI okay that's actually good
because what I can do is in main menu
I'll just do that
running out of time
uh and that should mean that
I can just do screen space UI here
and basically
let's do this we'll just do
but again I have to go recursively
through all of them
which didn't seem to work last time
which is why I'm a bit sussed about it
uh set opacity of children
set it to yeah a certain value but
whatever
and that isn't quite what apparently
oh that's right yeah because you need to
get the color separately
going quick here
so we'll just do set opacity of children
uh the main menu
texts two
the help screen transition
why
oh no sorry one minus help screen
transition
right
beautiful
okay oh
build build build
ah yeah that's fine I just ran it too
long yeah I know what qual renderer
crash you guys are getting
it's not a big deal
and this restarting Hazel helps it
um it doesn't matter like now but yeah
oh really
well yeah okay I don't think so
yeah I don't think so
it doesn't make sense
okay so full screen here
it just crashed for me
I think
right
what the heck happened
well Bad News Bears that crashed
and it's not even here as it is
oh come on man what why is it Frozen
what the heck
I literally can't do anything
I can't even end it because access is
denied what the heck
this is the worst
I'm gonna have to restart my computer
sorry stream
okay so that's actually a crash that
happens every time oh because eventually
get children
and why did that not happen in the
editor huh
and look this can't show me my code
yep
okay well
we might have to just not have that text
work like it did
unfortunately I don't know why that's
happening but
it just doesn't seem to work
I'm just making sure there's no other
weird scripts and stuff
and where's the camera
oh because this is null
why did I not save it
okay maybe this will fix it
okay where's ldjam.com
yeah that seems to have fixed it
oh close one all right that's it ship
ship ship ship
um what's the full screen true
I'll do a dist build I guess
which means this has to be on set
uh peda Peta destroyed us
PETA
what
ah
so it's just if instead of iftaf yeah
okay and that's it otherwise this builds
okay good
I really hope so
cameras about delivering coffee in a
stressful setting
more to come
uh uh how do I
make a game
this stupid thing
create new project
uh mono I might have to
do the uh dist thing
I just need to submit a URL and even if
it's empty I think that's fine
um so I need to probably do setup as
administrator
that's probably the problem
Windows Windows Windows
URL
can I just do that
what
did you say something
okay that built good
all right
thing
submission is so stressful
going through this by the way stream
sorry I wasn't showing you
yes gem
we're gonna make that link work in a
minute
uh is that done
publish
while the links here are just empty
because I need to upload the thing okay
done
why is there only three correct three
categories at least we have a submission
page and stuff
we can keep editing it forever
oh do not write me I checked the wrong
one
okay never mind okay we're up we're up
that's submission hour
um okay yeah well let's just submit it
now I mean we've got like five minutes
but you know there's no one's looking
um
Saving Private not captain
chino.exe
um this is how we do things we go to the
desktop we make a underscore release
folder that has to be called that
um we put this here
then we go to hazelnut oh that's that
builds probably not going to work by the
way but we need um what do we need we
need a resources mono
that's probably it
um we need to delete a lot of stuff from
resources but
yeah
um so in runtime layer application how
do we ship this game Ah that's off
that's good
um yeah the only thing we need is yeah
because obviously there's no command
line argument so the project path has to
be ld53 we'll call it
basically this is the little part that I
forgot to include
hopefully just runs by the way but
you know I guess we'll find out
okay so that's the new one
I really should just change the output
file name
no time uh okay resources we strip
I think we need fonts
probably not all of them but
um this this has gone renderer do we
need that I think so scripts we just
need Hazel script core I'm pretty sure
that's it
um everything else is elsewhere shaders
we don't need templates we don't need
textures we don't need we just need to
shade it back as well so that's what the
resources folder looks like and then we
have the
actual game folder
which I pinned here luckily for quick
access
um so let's copy
that into
here
I don't need all of it
because this is the raw assets as well
so we I think we just need I think I
don't think we need any of this
if I'm correct we just need
and we don't need that I think we need
that I don't know if we need the tree
View and we need the sound back I think
that's all we need wow it's kind of big
300 Meg
it'll come it'll compress well though
it'll compress well there probably
it's the environment map as well it's
kind of big I think
um
uh and then in here we don't need cash
for intermediates I think we just need
the hprodge
this should hopefully be correct
oh no I should have done a full screen
it worked
oh my gosh it just works that is the
best done but now I generated all these
files that I'm gonna have to manually
strip like logs
that's okay and cash
let's say we've got a build that kind of
works I guess config
oh yeah you're getting like the max
Graphics in this release as well so like
screen space Reflections on high like
this is going to be very bad for a lot
of people but we're gonna ship it with
um
yeah
and fonts like I don't know man I don't
think we need this
we need like probably one of the open
Sans fonts
we don't need a Roboto we don't need
that we do need that I think
okay I think this is it
yeah
wait what do you mean your font
no what do you mean it got rid off like
change it to be the one look
shh
100 FPS in full screen on my rig
ouch
um we might tweak some build settings
later okay good that's it guys
um sure uh I'm going to yeah I'll get
you guys a test in a minute
I guess I'll make a folder for it
I've had it's always private
and there's no icon yet but I'll we just
need to ship this out because it's 11
59.
um
it's not gonna upload in time but
oh what's all that this
why is that there
could be embedded textures I don't know
no but those files shouldn't be there
oh it's mono I accidentally shipped all
of mono
and Linux
I think just leave is what I need
isn't it yeah
cancel
um
I'm pretty sure I don't need these at
all
but I should test it
um
I'm putting it into a test director
because it will create fault look
there's still there's lots of stuff here
oh can I just take the ones from
dichotomy actually did you you haven't
updated them recently have you
because it's just because dichotomy is
ready to go
yeah
um I need to find that though
okay
where's the dichotomy I've deleted all
my dichotomies though
ready to go always
yeah
that sucks
we've already submitted we've already
submitted
that's fine though
three days I'm downloading dichotomy so
I can ship this game
okay I'm gonna try with this mono
Library
and hopefully it will just work
uh yeah it seems to done good enough for
me we got we got a few frames rendering
so that's good
uh all right cool done
um so I just need to make sure that
that's now in here as well
uh and then this is what we compress I'm
just trying to reduce the file size for
you guys I could have shipped this like
a while ago there's still some weird
stuff in there though
but this was a lot this compressed a lot
faster so
I'm guessing it's okay
I'm ready to upload man
200 Meg uh
protections no it's I I don't know I
think it's
I think it's the environment map it's
like half of that
we probably could have just done Dynamic
Sky maybe there should be like a peasant
Edition that's like for lower level well
I mean platforms considering what our
scene will look like I don't think we
needed a 4K texture
top learning guys
because it's 4K for each side right of
the cube
oh yeah we should have we should have
massively reduce the environment map
yeah like resolution
yeah yeah oh it might be tonight it's 2K
by default I think I don't think it's 4K
by default that would be crazy
but yeah it's Amazon compressed so it's
quite big all right
um
but yeah the link is just
I'll send the link into Autumn Chad chat
laughs
will you release the card also uh
probably not uh maybe for patrons
it'll be like you know that old thing
the like the rest like all the previous
games yeah because you need Hazel anyway
obviously for it well no not to play the
game but yeah if you want to edit it and
stuff
and build it you need Hazel so
I'll probably yeah so patreon accomplish
the channel a good place to plug this
you guys should go there and uh help
support
this struggle of a life of making your
own gay mansion
yeah Australian internet but also I'm
streaming so it's my upload speeds
obviously and Tim streaming that's it
um can you try and download it Peter
via the link
oh wait I have to click save
and we have no art so we're going to
start making the cover image and
everything but I've hit save now
yeah
if you're a gave me the right lane I'm
on it
uh yeah it might take a little bit
really
oh
wait what oh it's a draft
ah whoops okay check now
yeah done
I guess I should try downloading it
myself
getting the downloads up
damn two minutes to download
yeah the bandwidth is saturated
tell me the good news Peter
I I can't yet because it's not done
download it
yeah Tim's playing with audio
I'm watching a live stream
as well Peter oh you're watching mine
at least where I am right now oh you're
extracting are you
do this download where the heck is it oh
here it is let me extract all
yeah there's all this files we don't
need man
I don't get it though I copied mono guys
I want to do another release very soon
that's going to just not have half of
this stuff I don't know what happened
it's got to be in the mono directory
right
it's funny
where are all the are there hidden files
here did I pull an absolute Noob move I
think I may have just I think they were
all hidden files that I pushed out oh
good it's working for you
well that's it done it works guys okay
guys I've probably shipped it with a lot
of hidden files
hopefully not like you know my credit
card details but who knows so let me
just quickly uh redo it
just
ah whatever it works
yeah I saw that I don't know why as long
as it doesn't crash though
oh yeah I saw that but that didn't used
to happen
can you hit Ctrl F3 like what's your
frame rate and stuff
ah
it might because it's multi-threaded and
there's like
yeah that kind of sucks there's quite a
lot of flickering well it's okay I can
fix that
weird
oh yeah no that's probably just one long
frame when it does the chunk so it's
just for one frame it's so flickery
though I'm looking at your screen why
why it wasn't before at all I I spent a
long time testing the runtime like with
this game I'm in
no
what the heck happened
that's so sad I hate stuff
yeah
it doesn't run my computer yeah get a
better computer
oh I I committed a DOT get like a
committed the dot get folder
yeah that's so annoying
but it's okay I'll push another one out
in a minute I don't understand I did
show hidden files where are they huh
they're not here
oh it's in here
LOL
okay pushing a new one
I'll be pushing new ones all day
basically but yeah
yes yes
so it's about half it's 157 Meg now
it's more like it
oh
yeah what
I trashed yeah
yeah so play a game and then restarting
their questions
yeah I don't know what you guys did with
the restarting but I'll have to
investigate that well it was working
fine
it doesn't have a lot
I know it's just outside captured oh
right yeah
what's it called Peter when you finish
trying to upload your GPU drivers guys
if it doesn't work and if it still
doesn't work then we're just gonna iron
out bugs over the next week I don't know
so just uh yeah
and about to be yeah crash for Tim for
some reason
um okay I've updated it
I've updated all I've done is just the
mono it doesn't have mono
thing is
flickering log full of Vulcan errors
really can you tell me which Falconer is
oh I probably shipped shipped with
validation on oh
does that mean it's not gonna run if you
don't have Vulcan SDK installed
I don't know about that but yeah I
accidentally shipped with
our
um
did you have to like beat it twice no no
I I beat it once and when I before I
went to play maybe it's good that I
shared with walking validation
oh no okay people don't some people
don't have volcanistic hands told in the
surrounds well then who cares well no
welcome
I mean vulcan's gonna so that's gonna
slow down the CPU though having all
validation
oh I'm building Hazel now that's why
that didn't work
the flickering I'm really not happy with
the flickering because it shouldn't be
flickering
but yeah
my camera just spins when I start the
game do you have a controller connected
because sometimes that happens to me if
not then that sucks
but yeah there's a bunch of like welcome
validation although that that's imposed
that doesn't matter
uh oh I just yeah of course it just
disables validation if
you don't have it or whatever
yeah some people don't have flickering
for one person it just screams uh
uh the screen spins
um all tab doesn't work for some people
this all tab work for you guys
yeah yep I don't know
that's such is life you know we don't
have a
a week to do or a month to do QA for
this so it's just out
uh let me I guess upload it so this is
without validation I guess I'll try and
run it
this can't play if I shipped it with Git
though
with getting.vs nice well because they
were hidden man
I feel like you know what should happen
when you compress
something when you add something to a
zip archive it should be like hey man
you have hidden files here are you sure
like include hidden files exclude that
would be nice
I guess I'll play through it I don't
know
not the enemies I I missed my Sprint
feature
no I don't know I kind of like this game
to be honest it's kind of it's kind of
cool and I like the graphics a lot
of course it could be improved but like
you know we made this very quickly
I like the
like that's pretty dope
oh the sniper
do the guns work differently like this
oh this is my sniper's upside down
ah this is pretty dope like I won't lie
I like it this little tab work yes for
me yes as you can see
it the screen looks black for a bit but
that's just on stream
like in real life it's it's instant
oh a shotgun
assault rifle
I don't like the weapons you don't like
a swap you just consume them
it'd be great if you could stop oh by
the way I don't think it's flickering
for me honestly I just haven't noticed
so
it sometimes flickers
but I just I don't know how I don't know
if it would be a driver thing because it
doesn't stick around the editor does it
yeah it does it flicker in the editor
I like the shotgun it's pretty powerful
I like the SpongeBob footstep sound
effects yeah
hit what
yeah so that's why I'm I think it might
be a like some kind of runtime race
condition wait am I dead no I guess I
got coffee
I might actually complete this game
no you know what you know what would be
cool if there was an achievement for um
being able to complete the game without
aiming like without using right Mouse
button
it'd be like a hip fire or anything I
mean this is still running pretty well
for me over 100 FPS and I'm been playing
for a while which is good
the shotgun is great it's like an
instant kill oh
so I have to oh wait how do I drop the
coffee is that yeah but that's not that
is never told
to you oh that's it I did it
well yeah I guess you're right you have
to go to controls
I guess you have to kind of think about
that but yeah no it works guys a quit
would be good
yeah I think I'll spend the rest of the
week maybe polishing it because I don't
have that much work I have to put out a
video on Friday
um but aside from that I'm pretty free I
think so I might just polish this
like within limits because I think
you're allowed to do stuff
you're allowed to do some stuff
well yeah fix bugs but polishing I don't
know
it's just I guess I probably should make
a I probably should make another
mode like another no another Edition
that's like you know the jam submission
versus just like I wanted to improve the
game so it would be better for everyone
no flicker from me on a 1080. I have a
feeling I don't think that the flicker
is GPU at all
like I don't think I think it
it's just something to do with
um
I feel like it's something to do with
the way that
like I just think that the render thread
might get the wrong set of entity
submitted one frame when they change due
to something
but yeah
yeah strafing's fast it's like without
perk and Call of Duty stalker or
whatever where you can now control F3 is
to get that
I'm getting a flicker but only every 15
seconds it's probably when you go to a
different chunk by the way you have to
press alt f4 to close
and it should close instantly like like
it did here again the black screen is
just on stream
game doesn't come out for me yeah it'll
just crash without anything you can look
at the logs so inside
um the directory
uh let me just quickly bring this up
inside the directory
so this is what the game looks like
obviously when you get it inside the
directory there's a logs folder after
you run it and that might have an
information in it in fact we
have a lot here which probably disable
it
um
and then here's I kind of like the gun
sound effect it's like not bad
yeah and then you can see this is the
Hazelwood look thirteen thousand
I haven't played it played it with
headphones unfortunately so that's why
I guess I should get
like a nice screenshot or something
right
usually shotguns and games the missing
card points shouldn't really be a
problem
that's just fonts it couldn't load all
glyphs or whatever because those fonts
just don't have them I'm pretty sure
yeah I'm getting the flickering in the
runtime that's good
because yeah because if I wasn't like
that would be kind of
not the best
see I can't even get the
screenshot it's weird it's like it it
doesn't let me screenshot
I wonder why because I'm just I should
be just be running this bottle as full
screen or whatever
um
but it's oh that worked alt worked oh
that's that's a good screenshot it's
like the coffee is spilling out because
I'm getting shot
um
62 FPS at 4K yeah 4K is kind of heavy
because it's GPU bound as well
especially with Max settings because
it's got like screen special Reflections
on full and whatever
so
yeah
all right
um
I guess I probably should just pay have
base it in the whole thing that looks
kind of cool
this is gonna be the first I don't even
know the resolution or whatever
for uh you know
um
yeah everything's up it's just uh I'm it
doesn't have any screenshots but like
the links uh you can get there
everywhere you can get everywhere
okay
I'm gonna upload some images everywhere
I know
it's just everything is bad about it
I have a cover image finally
and then can I upload just a normal
image please Mike no
you have to like do some weird weirdo
stuff here don't you
upload image link above
do you mean the one below here hey
hey oh nice they put it right in the
middle of my sentence
put it first huh
that's not that's a good screenshot for
just hitting Prince crane
can you create a captain trainer channel
on Discord yes good idea
oh and I can put a coffee Emoji perfect
I better do that I have to like send
someone coffee and chat
I think
oh what I can't seem to create a channel
with emoji
or do I have to edit it later
the name
or does it have to be I think it has I
think it copy a Discord Emoji it doesn't
be like a utf-8
whatever I think
and it's called hot beverage
all right it should be public for you
guys
I'm gonna get the first one so in the
street under Studio yeah yeah people are
already posting that all right thanks uh
Maddie for posting that oh we'll take a
look at it
oh that's fine that's a on shutdown
crash those don't count
okay
um
yeah so I'll send the lottery can I it'd
be nice if I could pin
stuff hey YouTube can you do that no
pinning
be nice if I could pin oh I can pin oh
that's excellent thank you YouTube
that's already better than uh
oh
and I can even I can't edit the message
but
uh that's great that I can just
so and then
I'll just I'm crafting something
um
okay it's a thing
the player model
well it's not I I don't know I've grown
it's grown on me
it like look this is a nice shot like
well it's got a style you know it's just
it's not executed well this is nice this
was like uh
caught myself in the mirror this morning
looking good I I really like those guys
they're pretty cute yeah I like them as
well
I'm glad for this screenshot it's
holding it properly
yeah the sniper over
wait did I call it Saving Private
no Saving Captain Chino
oh
I called it Saving Captain Coffee and
that's a link as well oh well
know why guys it's because I'm tired
intentionally because can I upload the
URL here is that gonna be like I think I
can I
I'm done
do it a little bit before this
no we've got a rating on London there
I guess I need to replace this now
and I unfortunately can't even see the
whole message so that's the Rope thanks
YouTube I take back everything I said
you can probably just um
oh look it's here but can I just see the
full message man I guess I could go to
the links and kind of reconstruct it
that way but like it's
you're probably not really supposed to
have two of these
like I didn't think yeah
oh my emoji wait did it delete my emoji
good I like that emoji
I'll put two of them in fact
spamming my own chat it'll be funny if
you just dance me
okay links are updated
if you press escape the game gets stuck
huh don't press Escape then
I don't know it should just unlock the
cam like unlock the mouse if you press
Escape does that not work in the runtime
you can't be tired it's time to work on
the day one patch yeah
the
um the facts of being in the industry
day zero patch
something on Discord or you posted your
camera spinning on Discord sweet
let's watch it
I'm watching out I don't have to believe
me it's not downloading for me that
video so
about 20 seconds
oh this and you definitely don't have a
controller connected
Graphics table connected and sometimes
oh look it's he's already answered it
weird game crashes immediately yes
we'll do that sometimes
all right well yeah see I don't know I I
hate this whole concept of a game Jam
because it's kind of like you're tired
now you have to provide support like you
transition very quickly from making the
operator
you transition from making the game to
being like now let's do some customer
support
and like
kind of don't want to no but no this is
the real reason I brought this up was
because you're tired right after the
game Jam and you want to go to sleep and
or you want to just take a break but
then it's like but people aren't playing
my game now because I've submitted it
and they're probably rating it as well
because some absolute like
I don't even know what to call them no
just like some like some people for some
reason think it's a good idea to
transition from making a game for three
days immediately to playing people's
games
I don't get that there should be a
submission and then 24 hours after
submission rating starts
submit the rating has to be one of those
people who just spent the last three
years that's the problem man so if
you've been up for like three days
developing a game and now you kind of
have to there's probably a lot of noise
in the background because it's the
ambience all right it's the game still
running I swear it didn't even crash
because it actually if you feel a tab it
pauses by the way that's how you pause
um
yeah you're basically like
you you've been up for three days and
now you're writing games like I don't
know about you but I would just be angry
at all of them
yeah Peter agrees
yeah
so and there's no icon
this was a rough release but it works
actually for people so it's definitely
smoother than some releases we've done I
think oh yeah
if you open the controls and press enter
they disappear oh well
get what you get
130 FPS on 1080p37 laptop better than
expected yeah that's nice actually
you're getting better than me but I'm
not playing at a 1080 I'm playing at 25
because it's GPU bound that's the thing
so the higher your resolution because
I've got Quad HD like it runs at about
100 FPS on my 3080 desktop
oh I should play it on the QA
all right guys I'm just gonna play it on
the oh I've still got coffee what the
heck I didn't finish my coffee
hopefully it's still good yeah tastes
weird I did get an extra shot in it
though so I don't it could be just the
um I'm thinking tomorrow or early later
today when I wake up I'm gonna have a go
at maybe you know the next build of it
oh speaking of which advantage is booted
for me I forgot that's the default
option now
um
actually hang on Emily shipped her again
I don't know
what the link is right you have a league
is tired no I don't
uh because I asked do you have a leak
and you're like yeah but I don't know
what the link is
oh I think you just spent years in like
acknowledge you know just like something
that people say sure yeah figures like
you just said yeah sure
what the hell he's made a video on it of
like how she made the game
videos
is it Linux only a game
uh it was developed yes
it might be Linux only yeah bro so one
of the games that was shipped in this
lavender using Hazel is Linux only just
take the
um of course because the runtime
yeah but you need the you need to tell
the binary to obviously read the the
right um
like is it her well her binary wouldn't
work anyway so it wouldn't matter but
like what I mean is your binary for this
game wouldn't run that game
but you could obviously make it work in
like five minutes
yeah I might I might Saturday
oh
thank you
maybe it's just I'm actually wondering
if the project is straight up open
source I'm very GitHub
but you don't need it
oh what do you want to put you need it
for the asset registration or which you
ID to
launch I think but that's it why else
would you need it
all the project resources are compatible
with anyos or platform
I need to make a launch with graphic
settings because some peasants are
struggling
oh I I don't think she stripped her zip
file of mono and stuff like that oh yeah
it's 400 Megs damn
all right everyone I'm about to run it
on the QA machine will it work will my
will my camera Spin and will it perform
decently thing is though
I think it will because you're on
Windows right
60 FPS oh but vsync is on everyone
so no how are you getting 110 frames
because I'm 144 Hertz oh wait is it
really yeah
I don't want to use too much
[Laughter]
why does control shift T not work for
you what's uh
no no well I all tab to the right window
it's all shift R to open a file is that
what you're trying to do old wait old
shift or tips like this okay board
where's the old key
yeah true
that's what you were checking
wait all right yeah
but look GPU weighs 12. so GPU time is
six milliseconds so that's a lot of this
is actually a good frame rate
is
yeah that's nice but it's still like
it's nowhere near something else oh this
is like unplayable there
it's amazing
but yeah 60 FPS on the steam averaging
computer so
very shiny
that's the compass
like pranks happening as well
that was
feels kind of
uh it feels slower because I'm used to
144 Hertz right now but doesn't feel
like
it's good yeah
you thought we had it bad
apparently Emily crashed 67 pounds yeah
I heard about that holy [__] I've landed
Linux I I heard most of it was related
to physics too
relationships only to that yeah
uh she didn't mention something about
physics
yeah this works I don't believe it
um all right
so that's it I think guys do you wanna
grab lunchtime or are you gonna head off
okay Tim and I are gonna have our
celebratory burrito from this Mexican
place that we have after every London
there
don't know how it started
yeah but definitely because that one was
closed speaking of voyage it might be
closed but in that case I guess upon me
they used to be open for lunch now they
changed the dinner on there I think so
for weekends but I'll check
oh true
you don't want to buy me
oh it's open it's weird the burrito
places open everyone all right um
we'll see we'll see
um what was I going to say yeah guys I'm
gonna like I think I'll keep working a
bit later today because since I did
sleep at night
like well for four hours but still
probably even less than four hours by
the time I fell asleep but
um I'm probably I guess I'll keep
streaming when I come back after lunch
maybe we'll see what happens though I
need to like you know contact my family
and see like if they need me or
something
but if they don't need me then I'm I'm
all yours stream and I'm gonna add a
launcher to this game and maybe try and
fix the flickering uh and add a launcher
with different with the different
tiering options that we have in Hazel so
that you guys can like set your
resolution lower or turn off screen
space Reflections or turn the quality to
low or whatever
um so you can get it to perform better
so that is um
yeah but thank thank you guys for being
with us on the journey I to be honest I
before I left uh last night to go home
at like 2 A.M and sleep I did um I did
not think we would get here like I
really did not see it coming together
like this
um but you know it came together rather
quickly at the end obviously I had time
to do both sound effects and add the
screen space kind of text rendering as
well this morning so I think that was
good because I was able to get some
sleep then I just got up at like 6 30
a.m was my alarm and then I got a nice
nice strong coffee
I was at the cafe at like exactly 7am as
they opened I looked I walked in I
looked at my clock am I watching it was
like 7 A.M in like 40 seconds or
something just walking in right on time
getting the coffee and um
and that gave me the kind of boost to
just quickly do all of that last minute
engine stuff
um so yeah
what is the best way to send a donation
that doesn't take a bunch from you
I would say probably
tough
because patreon takes five percent
because I'm on the original plan
um you know you want to buy me lunch
um I think
I don't know yeah I actually don't have
an answer to that
you just met you maybe you can just
become a patron and get access to Hazel
and play around with that that would be
a win-win as well
for you possibly
and you can always cancel after one
month if you don't want to keep going
um all right guys I might actually one
other thing I'll plug this as well I
recently introduced a new tier on
patreon which is the five dollar per
month tier so for 10 bucks you get
access to Hazel uh for 25 you get access
it's just a a bigger tier for those who
want to support more but you basically
get
um access to uh all of the games we've
made in all of the assets
um and also we do monthly we've started
doing them again as of last month we did
one we do partner Hangouts so basically
it's like a it's like a a voice Channel
a video voice channel on Discord
actually we did it as a stage last time
um and then you guys can like we can all
talk and ask questions and with like the
whole team for like an hour or an hour
and a half or whatever so uh that's the
25 here and then a five dollar tier
which is uh new as it's always been
around but I've started doing more
things for it now so I do like a weekly
deep dive technical video I've only done
one so far but I'm gonna do them weekly
that's the plan so I'm I might actually
break down
this journey in detail because like I'll
I'll probably still make a video just
public for YouTube but obviously like
you know YouTube like it's good to make
15 20 minute videos that are a bit
edited and a bit to the point and to try
and maximize engagement and it's not
really good for like really long form
chill videos so that's why I've started
doing them on patreon so like it's just
like a cup it can be like a couple hours
of me just talking and being like this
was blah blah blah it was almost like a
live stream so if you're interested in
that patreon.com the channel
um the money from there goes to support
like you know Tim and Peter obviously
because they're employees but um you
know this office space and basically it
gets kind of reinvested in the game
engine so if you want to see Hazel
succeed and have more features or you
just want to support the project then
patreon.com the channel thank you guys
for
being around what happens if we cancel a
10 subscription you use yes you do lose
access but you still have it for a month
so it works like Netflix it works like
Netflix
or any other streaming service you still
you can basically I'm pretty sure you
can as long as you sign up and then go
to get.hazal engine.com to activate your
because it's automatic you just need to
connect to your GitHub and patreon
accounts like together and then you'll
get an invite on GitHub you won't be
removed until the 30 days passes so that
should work and I mean if it doesn't for
whatever reason just reach out to me
all right thank you guys
um
probably make a few yeah I don't know I
kind of like this game to be honest I
say this after every let them dare but
I'm hoping that I will have time and the
desire to work on it a little bit and
maybe just make it something
a bit more fun
um and I don't know like there's a lot
of I think there's a lot of potential I
like the way I just like the graphics as
well the way the hex tiles look uh it
could even be a different game but yeah
I think I might
work on it so I might be back in a
couple hours gonna have a little bit of
a break and then I'm gonna as I
mentioned I'm gonna start working on
like the launcher and do all of that
stuff
all right thank you guys for watching
hope you enjoy the game that it's pinned
up there I'll add it to the first line
of the description of this VOD as well
um but yeah
I was a good let him there I think
and I'm quite happy with the game all
right see you guys love you all thank
you for watching bye
stupid stream ends
where's the stop button